GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME BEFORE WE
BEGIN I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO READ
SOME DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION INTO THESE HEARING
TO HELP INSURE THE SAFETY OF
EVERYONE HERE. WELL ALLOWING
FULL PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE
DISCUSSION TODAY WE ARE HAVING
AN IN PERSON HEARING IN THE
STATE CAPITOL IN ROOM FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN. THE
PANELISTS ON THE EDGE AND THERE
ARE PARA MOSTLY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY. FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL BEGAN WITH THOSE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM FOLLOWED BY PHONE
TESTIMONY. EACH PERSON WILL HAVE
WILL. WE'LL HAVE UP TO ONE
MINUTE TO SPEAK. THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT AND- TO
CONNECT THIS ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE ON THE
SCREEN IF YOU'RE STREAMING THIS
HEARING. JUST IN CASE THE NUMBER
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND
THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN.
IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS
PLEASE CONTACT THE FAMILY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX. THREE
ONE NINE. TWO ZERO NINE NINE
FOR. FOR I'M GONNA GO BACK I
APOLOGIZE THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE
I GAVE YOU LISTING CORRECT ON
REPEAT THE PHONE NUMBER AND THE
ACCESS CODE AGAIN. SO THE NUMBER
TO CONNECT IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN IN THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR FOUR
SEVEN AGAIN THIS IS AVAILABLE ON
THE WEBSITE AND AS WELL ON THE
SCREEN OF YOUR STREAMING THIS
HEARING. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE.
TWO ZERO NINE NINE AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. WE WILL
NOT BE TAKING ANY BUT CITY.
TODAY WE'LL BE DISCUSSING BETTER
PROPOSALS FROM THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH IN THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. FOR EACH
ITEM THE SPEAKERS ARE LISTED IN
SPEAKING ORDER IN THE AGENDA. I
ALSO WANT TO TAKE A MINUTE- TO
WELCOME A NEW MEMBER TO THE
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WATER
WELCOME. WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE YOU
HERE. OUR FIRST ITEM IS COURT
BACKLOGS AND REMOTE HEARINGS AND
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED
WITH THE PANELISTS AND THEY
COULD SPEAK IN THE ORDER. LISTED
IN THE AGENDA. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ROBERT A
YOUNG AND I AM THE CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER FOR THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. FOLLOW UP WITH
A BACKLOG DATA NOW FROM THE
START OF THE PANDEMIC IN MARCH
TWO THOUSAND. UP TO THE NEWS
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE. HOW
WE CAN. CONTINUE TO COLLECT DATA
ON A QUARTERLY BASIS. SO WE
DETERMINED BACKLOG BY LOOKING AT
TWO THINGS. OUR COMPANY FILINGS
ARE COMING IN AND HOW FAST CAN
THE COURTS PROCESS. IF THE COURT
CANNOT PROCESS ALL THE FINALLY
COMING IN THERE'S A BACKLOG. OF
THAT BACKLOG IS DRIVEN BY WHAT'S
CALLED CLEARANCE RATE. AND THIS
IS THE MEASUREMENT OF HOW FAST
THE COURTS CAN PROCESS DEFINED.
A PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC IF THE
COURT HAD A HUNDRED FILINGS COME
IN. THEY COULD PROCESS EIGHTY
SIX OF THEM. WHICH IS A
CLEARANCE RATE OF EIGHTY SIX
PERCENT. IT WOULD RESULT IN A
BACKLOG OF FOURTEEN CASE. FOR
THE OVERALL PANDEMIC PERIOD THE
FRENCH CLEARANCE RATE IS EIGHTY
THREE PERCENT. WHICH IS SLIGHTLY
LOWER THAN THE PRE PENTOMIC
RIGHT 86% R. FOR THE- ALL- IN
THE BEGINNING OF THE CLEARANCE
RATE WENT DOWN ACTUALLY TO
SEVENTY THREE PERCENT. BUT NOW
IT'S RECOVERED AND HOVERED
AROUND EIGHTY SIX THE NOT EIGHTY
NINE PERCENT. OVER THE PAST
THREE QUARTERS. IN MOST CASES
TYPES OF FILINGS ARE DOWN ABOUT
34% COMPARED TO PRE PANDEMIC
TIMES WHICH PROVIDES. SOME
BUFFER FOR THE COURTS TO CATCH
UP. IN ADDITION THE COURTS WERE
ABLE THEIR CLIENTS
RATES PRINT PANDEMIC DUE TO
THEIR ABILITY TO PROVIDE REMOTE
PROCEEDINGS IN MANY AREAS. SO
FOR EXAMPLE IN THE JUVENILE AREA
WHERE REMOTE PROCEEDINGS ARE
WIDELY USED ARE THE PANDEMIC
CLEARANCE RATES EXCEEDED PRE
PLANNED ROUTES. OUR GENERAL
CHALLENGES THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC HAVE BEEN FOCUSED
AROUND PHYSICAL DISTANCE
CONSTRAINTS ARE WHICH REDUCE THE
COURT ROOM CAPACITY. AND
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN OTHER AREAS
BOTH THE PRIVATE AND THE PUBLIC
SECTOR. SO FOR EXAMPLE CREE
PANDEMIC VACANCY RATES HOVER
AROUND 629% AT SEVERAL COURTS
AND DURING THE HEIGHT OF THE
PANDEMIC. THAT RATE INCREASE.
NINE TO FIFTEEN PERCENT. ARE AND
AS OF THIS MONTH THOSE COURTS
ACTUALLY HAVE A AVERAGE VACANCY
RATE NOW OF TEN TO SEVENTEEN
PERCENT. SO WHILE SOME COURTS
EVERITT CURRENTLY THEIR PRE
PANDEMIC VACANCY RATES ARE MANY
HAVE NOT. OTHER VACANCY IS DUE
TO TWO PRIMARY FACTORS BUT THE
FIRST IS DIFFICULTY IN FILLING
VACANCIES AND THE SECOND IS IN
MANAGING COVERT EXPOSURES. ARE
AGAIN FOR EXAMPLE IN ONE COURT.
A COURT ROOM CLERK JOB POSTING
WHICH TYPICALLY RESULT IN ABOUT
FIFTY APPLICANTS FREE PANDEMIC.
BUT NOW ONLY ELEVEN O'CLOCK.
ANOTHER COURT WAS ABLE TO HIRE A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN PEOPLE
IN THE FIRST HALF OF THE FISCAL
YEAR. BUT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FOUR PEOPLE LEFT DURING THAT
SAME PERIOD. BUT DURING THIS
PERIOD WE ALSO SAW THE DELTA
VARIANT AND A HIGH RATE OF
COVERT EXPOSURE I WHICH FOR
STAFF TO ISOLATE OR PRODUCE A
NEGATIVE COVERT TASK. I WHICH
WAS DIFFICULT TO OBTAIN AT THE
TIME DUE TO TESTING SHORTAGE.
REGARDING REGARDING THE A
BACKLOG OF FILINGS BY DATA
SHOWING THAT BACKLOG THE
PRIMARIES THE FOCUS. IN THE
CRIMINAL AREAS WITH THE LARGEST
BACKLOG IN FELONY. AND THEN BOTH
IN THE TRAFFIC AND NON TRAFFIC
MISDEMEANOR CASE. WITH THE
SMALLER BACK LOG IN UNLIMITED
CIVIL CASES AND NO BACKLOG IN
LIVE AT LIMITED CIVIL. ARE THESE
ARE THE BRANCH RIGHT ESTIMATES
AND INDIVIDUAL COURT BACKLOGS
MAY VERY. SO THE COURTS THAT ARE
REPORTING- BACKLOGS IN THE
CRIMINAL AREA ARE REPORTING FOR
MAIN DRIVERS THE FIRST ONE IS
VIDEO REMOTE PROCEEDINGS ARE NOT
AS AVAILABLE NOR IS WIDELY USED
IN CRIMINAL AS ANOTHER CASE
TYPES. SECONDLY OUR PARTY SEEM
WILLING LESS WILLING TO SETTLE
THE CASE AND- A THIRD OF THE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE BUT I JUST
MENTIONED AT THE COURTS- IS
EXACERBATED FOR CRIMINAL CASE
PROCESSING DUE TO THE DEPENDENCY
ON JUSTICE PARTNERS WHO ARE ALSO
EXPERIENCING SIMILAR WORKFORCE
CHALLENGES. FINALLY FELONIES ONE
OF THE CASE TYPES WERE FINDING
DIPPED SHORT OF EARLY IN THE
PANDEMIC- BUT QUICKLY RETURNED
TO PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS SO COURTS
DID NOT HAVE A CHANCE TO CATCH
UP. LIKE THEY DID IN OTHER CASE
TYPES WERE FILING VOLUMES
REMAINED LOWER THAN PRE PLANNED
. IN ALL CASE TYPES COURTS ARE
SEEING PARTY'S LESS WILLING TO
SETTLE THEIR KIDS. NOW COVERT
EXPOSURES ARE ALSO AFFECTING
JURY TRIALS BUT WITH A SLIGHT
REDUCTION IN JURORS BEING ABLE
TO SERVE PROXIMATE WITH 527%
THAT A FEW COURTS. ABOUT A
BIGGER IMPACT IS WHEN THE
SELECTED JUROR BECOMES EXPOSED
TO THE VIRUS OR EXPOSE OR
SOMEONE IS TESTED POSITIVE WHICH
RESULT IN THE ENTIRE JURY
NEEDING TO ISOMERS. ARE IN ONE
COURT A FORTY EIGHT JURY TRIAL
TOOK TWO WEEKS BECAUSE OF THAT.
NOW WE ALSO- APPRECIATE THE
SUPPLEMENTAL BACKLOG FUNDING
THAT WAS PROVIDED TO THE COURT.
THAT A- ADDITIONAL FUNDING WAS
USED TO HIRE TEMPORARY HELP.
WHEN I RECRUITING CHALLENGES
HAVE BEEN HAPPENING IRWIN
STAFFER TEMPORARY OUT ON LEAVE
AND THAT'S HELPED REDUCE THE
GOING BACK WHILE. SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDING HAS ALSO BEEN USED TO
PAY FOR TEMPORARY FACILITY
RENTALS IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ARE SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO.
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE PUBLIC.
SO LOOKING FORWARD WE CONTINUE
TO COLLECT DATA ABOUT THE
BACKLOG. AND AS WE CONTINUE TO
FOLLOW MEASURES TO ADDRESS THE
PANDEMIC. OUR COURTS WILL STILL
STRUGGLE WITH THE EFFECTS OF
EXPOSURES AND PHYSICAL DISTANCE
HOWEVER BECAUSE THE PANDEMIC
BEGINS TO SUBSIDE. WE ANTICIPATE
COURTS ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
REDUCE THE BACKLOG OVER TALK.
THANK YOU. HI THIS IS HEATHER
CREDIT I AM THE CHIEF
INFORMATION OFFICER FOR THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL CALIFORNIA JUST
TO GIVE YOU A BRIEF UPDATE ON AB
AT SEVEN SIXTEEN AND THE B. C.
P. ASSOCIATED WITH THAT- THIS B.
C. P. IS SPECIFICALLY TO ADDRESS
THE OLDER INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS
WITHIN EACH OF THE COURT ROOMS
AND HOW THEY WILL ASSIST IN
PROMOTING OUT REMOVAL
PROCEEDINGS AND ACCESS TO THE
TRIAL COURTS I TO THE PUBLIC AS
WELL. SO I HAD THIS REALLY IS TO
REPLACE MUCH OF THE OLD AUDIO
EQUIPMENT THAT WAS INSTALLED
OVER TWENTY YEARS AGO THAT
REALLY DOESN'T- ALIGNED WELL
WITH THE NEW TECHNOLOGY DIGITAL
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS OUT THERE AND
THAT IS THE FUNDAMENTAL BASIS
FOR THIS REQUEST IS FOR ALL OF
THOSE COURTROOMS THAT ARE OLDER
THAN TWENTY YEARS OF AGE THAT WE
WOULD UPGRADE THAT UNDERLYING
INFRASTRUCTURE SO THAT WE CAN
NOW RUN THE NEW TECHNOLOGY AND
DIGITAL TECHNOLOGY THAT WE HAVE
INVESTED IN OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS. THANK YOU. SO
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE BEEN NOT THIS
AREA. THANK YOU FOR THE
APARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD. YES I JUST YOUR
ONLINE DEPARTMENT FINANCE TO
EXPAND ON THE TV SHOW COUNCILS
PRESENTATION JUST WANTED TO
POINT OUT THAT THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT HAD INCLUDED
SIXTY MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND FOR THE TRIAL COURTS TO
ADDRESS BACKLOGS REFLECT WASTE.
RESULTING FROM THE COVENANTING
PANDEMIC IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THIS MONEY CAN ALSO BE
USED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE FISCAL YEAR. I THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
ALSO INCLUDED THIRTY MILLION
LONGTIME GENERAL FUND TO ADDRESS
CERTAIN CRIMINAL CASE BACKLOGS.
I'M HAPPY. TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MY HOUSE
. THANK YOU FOR IS THAT- I
WANTED TO RETURN TO THE
BACKLOGS. I WANNA I WANNA
KNOWLEDGE THE PROGRESS THAT HAS
BEEN DONE TO REDUCE THE COURT
BACKLOGS. THUS FAR- AND- WANTED
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION WITH
INFORMATION ABOUT FELONY TRIALS
ON IN JURY. JURY JURY ISSUES
THAT HAVE COME UP ALONG THE WAY
IN JURY TRIALS IS THIS A SIMILAR
IS- THE IS THE BACKLOG FOR THE
MISDEMEANOR CASES SMILAR TO THE
FELONY TRIALS ARE CERTAIN
DIFFERENT REASON WHY WE HAVEN'T
SEEN- AS MUCH PROGRESS AS IS
SEEN AS SOME OF THE OTHER AREAS.
YES IT'S SIMILAR. OKAY AND THEN
FOR THE TECHNOLOGY REQUEST FOR
THE COURTS DOES THIS QUALIFY AS
THE CELL EXCLUDABLE EXPENSE.
COULD YOU PLEASE CLARIFY THAT
EXCLUDED EXPENSE. THE F. SL SA
L. THIS IS THIS IS LIKE COMPUTER
JUDICIAL COUNCIL IF I MAY THAT
MIGHT BE A QUESTION FOR- POSTED
APARTMENT OF FINANCE- WHEN I
WOULD TRY TO CLEAR OUT ALL THE
SALIX WOULD WILL RULES IN ORDER
DEFERRED TAX QUESTION TO THEM
THANK YOU THANK YOU DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. I JUST YOUR MIND BUT
NOTHING I DON'T TO BE THAT. TO
MY MANAGER ABOUT THAT ALL BE
ABLE TO GET BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. YOU CAN GET THE
ANSWER TO THIS TO PAY. THAT THE
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE QUESTION ON
THIS MISTER STONE. THANK YOU SO
APPRECIATE TO JUDICIAL QUE
PRETTY THAT THE NUMBERS HERE AND
IN THE WORK TO REDUCE THE
BACKLOG. MORE HEARING DIFFERENT
THINGS REALLY FROM DIFFERENT
COURTS IN BECAUSE WE HAVE SO
MANY DIFFERENT COURTS. ARE YOU
SEEING. SIMILAR ABILITY TO
ADDRESS A BACKLOG IN EACH COURT
OR ARE THERE AREAS THAT STILL
NEED SOME WORK. EVERY COURT IS
DIFFERENCE AND SO- THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING THAT WAS
PROVIDED TO THE COURT IS HELPFUL
IN THE AREAS THAT I HAD
MENTIONED BOTH IN TERMS OF. OUR
TEMPORARY HELP AND- RENTALS FOR
FACILITIES NOT TECHNIQUE FOR
USING THE MONEY IN THE SAME WAY
HOWEVER THE MAJORITY OF THE
COURTS ARE USING. THAT MONEY FOR
TEMPORARY HELP- AND SO AGAIN
DEPENDS ON THE INDIVIDUAL COURT-
BUT THE ARE ADDRESSING IT AS
BEST AS THEY CAN WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY HAVE. SO
WHAT ARE SOME STRATEGIES A
DIFFERENT COURTS ARE USING THEM
TO REDUCE THE BACKLOG. SO ONE OF
THE STRATEGIES. AS I HAVE
MENTIONED IS TO USE OUR
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING FOR A
TEMPORARY HELP TO AS I MENTIONED
ONE OF THE BIG DRIVERS IS WHEN
PEOPLE GO OUT. AS A RESULT OF- A
EXPOSURE OR INFECTION AND SO AS
THOSE PEOPLE GO OUT ON ONE OF
THE TECHNIQUES TO BRING ON
TEMPORARY PEOPLE TO- HELP WITH
THAT. THE OTHER EXAMPLE I HAD
MENTIONED WAS AROUND HOW
LIMITATIONS IN FACILITIES ARE
AND SO IF THERE'S THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR EXAMPLE TO HAVE
A RENTAL OF A- EXTERNAL
FACILITY. THAT'S BEING DONE
HOWEVER ESPECIALLY IN THE
CRIMINAL AREA WHERE THERE IS THE
HIGH DEPENDENCY ON THE
AVAILABILITY OF JUSTICE PARTNERS
ARE SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING. CANNOT
HELP THEIR- OKAY IN ARE YOU TRY.
THOUGH COURT BY. THERE IS THE
ABILITY TO CLEAR UP THAT THE
BACKLOG AND THEIR STRATEGY SINCE
YOU SAY THE ROLE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT IT'S HARD FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND IS THAT. WHAT WE HEAR
FROM FRATERNITIES ACROSSTHE
STATE IS VERY DESPERATE AND SO I
APPRECIATE THAT OVERALL IT LOOKS
GOOD I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE
HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING OF WHERE
THERE MIGHT BE CHALLENGES WHICH
COURTS ARE STRUGGLING WHICH
COURTS ARE DOING THAT. RIGHT SO
WE DON'T HAVE AT THIS POINT- THE
DATA AT THE INDIVIDUAL LEVEL I'M
PREPARED FOR YOU. HOWEVER WE DO
WORK WITH EACH OF THE INDIVIDUAL
COURTS AND HAVE RECEIVED
FEEDBACK FROM THEM IN TERMS OF
THE STRATEGIES THAT THEY'RE
USING- YOU ADDRESS THE BACKLOG
AND THAT'S ALSO PART OF THE BEST
PRACTITIONERS ACROSS THE COURT.
OKAY GET IT. I GET CONCERNS WHEN
. WE HEAR EXAMPLES SORT OF COURT
BY COURT AND IT'S A LOT OF
ATTORNEYS PRACTICE IN IN
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS AND WHEN
THEIR EXPERIENCES ARE DIFFERENT
JURISDICTION TO JURISDICTION.
THAT BECOMES A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNING AND THEN THE SAME
QUESTIONS ESSENTIALLY ON. THE
REMOTE ACCESS I'M HEARING THE
SAME THING THAT REMOTE ACCESS IS
WORKING SUMMERS IN AND NOT IN
OTHERS WHAT WHAT'S BEING DONE TO
ENSURE THAT RESOURCE ARE BEING
INVESTED WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE AS MUCH
CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE COURTS AS
POSSIBLE HELLO SURE SO TO
ADDRESS YOUR FIRST POINT ABOUT
THE INCONSISTENCY AROUND OF THE
WAVE THAT- THE BACKLOGS HAVE
AFFECTED THE INDIVIDUAL COURTS-
THAT'S REALLY DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC BECAUSE THE PANDEMIC
HAS AFFECTED EACH INDIVIDUAL
COUNTY IN VERY DIFFERENT WAYS SO
FOR EXAMPLE IN SOME COUNTIES
WERE SAYING. THERE'S NOT A HUGE
NUMBER OF INFECTIONS AND SO-
THERE'S EIGHT LOWER BACK WHILE
IN SOME COUNTIES AS THE HIGHEST
LEVEL IN OF INFECTION AND IMPACT
ON THE PANDEMIC AND SAW HIGHER
IMPACT ON THE BACKLOG AND SO IT
REALLY VARIES BY I CALLED THE
LOCAL- THE LOCAL AREA IMPACTED
WITH REGARDS TO REMOTE
PROCEEDINGS A REMOTE
PROCEEDINGS- IS HIGHLY DEPENDENT
ON THE AVAILABLE TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE AT A PARTICULAR
COURT SO THE COURTS HAVE BEEN
PRETTY PROACTIVE. IN INVEST IN
REMOTE. ARE AND THE THREE. SOME
OF THE END OF FUNDING THAT WAS
PROVIDED COURTS WERE ABLE TO-
IMPLEMENT REMOTE TECHNOLOGY
HOWEVER THERE ARE A LOT OF
COURTHOUSES IN COURT ROOMS THAT
HAVE AGING INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
SO THIS PENDANT- DESCRIBE A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE PROPOSAL TO
REALLY BRING UP THE COURTS TO
HAVE OLD INFRASTRUCTURE SO
THERE'S MORE CONSISTENCY THERE
SO THAT THERE'S A MORE
CONSISTENT ENVIRONMENT. ACROSS
THE COURTS AS WELL BECAUSE SOME
ISSUES RELATED TO VIDEO SOME
HAVE- ISSUES RELATED TO SAMPLE.
RIGHT I THINK WOULD BE HELPFUL
FOR US IN THESE TWO CATEGORIES
THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT TO
GET. A LITTLE BIT MORE GRANULAR
DATA. COUNTY BY COUNTY THAT WE
UNDERSTAND. WHERE THINGS ARE
WORKING OR OR WHAT'S NOT BUT I
WOULD CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY WELL- I THINK MR
STONE- ASK FOR ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AS FAR AS WE TRY TO
MAKE SURE BEING EQUITABLE ACROSS
THE STATE INCONSISTENCY
APPRECIATE THAT INFORMATION WHEN
IT'S AVAILABLE WHAT. IT SHARE
WITH THE COMMITTEE. WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO OUR SECOND ISSUE
WHICH IS A TRIAL COURT EQUITY
FUNDING. AND THE PANELISTS MAY
BE AN- THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOHN WORK
LIVES. THE CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE
OFFICER WITH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AND I WISH TO THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU TODAY. BOB THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PROPOSAL THE EYES AS
YOUR AGENDA- DOES A VERY NICE
JOB AND FRAMING THE ISSUE- ARE
CHIEF JUSTICE THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL OUR COURTS. ARE STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS PROPOSAL WERE
GRATEFUL TO THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS
PROPOSAL- WHICH WOULD A-
LONGSTANDING STRUCTURAL ISSUES-
FUNDING GAPS WITHIN THE BRANCH.
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE EQUITY
FUNDING OF A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. WOULD GO OUT TO OUR
LOWEST POINT THE COURT- THERE
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTEEN COURTS
THAT OF. OUR UNDER OUR STATEWIDE
AVERAGE. OUR LITTLE SCORED B.
73% FUNDED FOR WORKLOAD- WELL.
AS YOU TELL OF LOS ANGELES FOR
EXAMPLE IS JUST UNDER 75% FUNDED
FOR. WORKLOAD ORANGE COUNTY
ANOTHER LARGE CHORDS. ABOUT 78%
SAN ABOUT SEVENTY PER- AND SO.
THIS IS VITAL IMPORTANT UPSET
HELP COURTS OF THEIR UNDER I GET
THAT LOWER SPINE COURTS THE
STATE- IF YOUR ACCOUNT SO BE
ALLOCATING THESE DOLLARS TO THE
WORK THOSE COURT SPECIFICALLY
AND IT WENT UP TO STABILIZE THE
SERVICE HOURS- WITHIN OUR COURTS
DAYS COURTS ARE OPEN TO THE
PUBLIC- IT WOULD PROVE EMPLOYEE
RETENTION RATES- BY RESTORING
INCREASING STOCK LEVELS. UP BUT
WOULD ALSO IMPROVE SERVICE EVERY
BY REDUCING WEIGHT THE CASE TIME
FOR IN PROCESSING THE WASTE NOT
VERY VERY IMPORTANT TO THE
PUBLIC AT CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT ALL RIGHT IT'S
GOING BY- JUDGE SINGER. SO FROM
. SANTA CLARA AS WELL AS- ARE
PROPER- JUDGES READ ALL JUDGES
STATE WHY. YEAH WELL AS KEVIN
HARRIGAN EXACTLY OFFICER FORTY.
AND IT'S THE VOICE ALL OF COURT
- EXACTLY SINCE THE WITH
STOCKTON SEE IF YOU HAVE ANY.
DO WE HAVE THE L. A. LIVE UP
THIS READY TO GO. I GUESS AND I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND NEED
ONLY WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE INSURE THAT
THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING PROVIDED.
AS WELL AS HOW IT'S ALLOCATED
REFLECTS LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES
SERVICE THE GOAL OF PROMOTING
FISCAL EQUITY AMONGST THE TRIAL
COURTS IS. IT HAS MERIT THE GOAL
OF MERIT AS IT PROMOTES EQUAL
ACCESS TO JUSTICE ACROSS THE
STATE. HOWEVER IT'S CURRENTLY
UNCLEAR HOW EXACTLY THE MONEY
WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED TO ACHIEVE
THAT S. AS ON THAT DECISION IS
GOING TO BE LEFT TO JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. WE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
THERE ARE DIFFERENT WAYS OF
PROMOTING FISCAL EQUITY WHICH
CAN IMPACT THE NUMBER OF COURTS
THAT RECEIVE FUNDING AS WELL AS
HOW MUCH THEY RECEIVE. SO FOR
EXAMPLE. THE COURTS HAVE A
WORKLOAD FORMULA AND THAT
BASICALLY IDENTIFIES THE AMOUNT
OF FUNDING RELATIVE TO WORKLOAD
THAT- A COURT NEEDS TO KIND OF
ADDRESS THAT WORKLOAD. AND SO
THE FUNDING COULD BE TARGETED TO
THE COURTS BELOW THE STATEWIDE
AVERAGE AS KIND OF REFERENCED BY
MR WARDLAW AND HIS COMMENTS
WHICH IS WHAT WE DID IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
ACCORDING COULD BE TARGET TO HIT
THE DESIGNATED FUNDING
PERCENTAGE SO THAT ALL COURTS
ARE AT LEAST A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE OF MONEY. WE WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT OTHER. COULD ALSO
BE CONSIDERED- MOST NOTABLY THE
THINGS THAT YOU TALKED ABOUT IN
TERMS OF ISSUE ONE IN TERMS OF
ADDRESSING PANDEMIC RELATED
IMPACTS SUCH AS BACKLOGS AND
DELAYS. IN COURT PROCEEDINGS AND
THIS COULD HELP ADDRESS EQUITY
IN TERMS OF PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE
COURTS AND HOW QUICKLY CASES CAN
BE RESOLVED. SO IN LINE WITH
THIS ONE OPTION THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER IS TO PROVIDE
SOME OR ALL OF THE REQUESTED
FUNDING IN THE BUDGET YEAR. TO
ADDRESS CAN DEMOCRAT LATE
IMPACTS- TO HELP WITH THIS
LEGISLATURE COULD HAVE THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH- PROVIDE MORE
DATA OR REPORT FURTHER IN THE
SPRING. MORE UPDATED INFORMATION
AND THEN THE FUNDING IN FUTURE
YEARS COULD BE ALLOCATED TO
ENSURE THAT ALL COURTS HAVE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF FUNDING SUCH
AS EIGHTY FOUR POINT 5% OF THEIR
IDENTIFY NEAT. THANK YOU HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I JUST YEAR
AMONG DEPARTMENTS FINANCE THAT
NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU AND SO- AND HAS
IN EQUITY AND ENHANCING ACCESS
TO JUSTICE I THINK IT'S THE GOAL
THAT WE ALL. HAVE BUT MY
QUESTION IS SIMILAR TO PASS
PROPOSALS THAT HAVE COME TO THE
COMMITTEE ABOUT THE DETAILS.
ENSURING THAT WE WILL BE USING
THE MONIES FOR. FOR OUR GOAL AND
TRACKING THAT AND AN ASSESSMENT
TO BEHIND THAT- IN SEOUL. UNDER
THE CURRENT PROPOSAL DID YOU
DISLIKE COUNCIL IS GOING TO COME
UP WITH THE DISTRIBUTION
FORMULA. IS THAT CORRECT. BONTA
I'M SURE JOHN WOULD LOG IN AND-
I WILL COMMENT THAT. AS WE ENTER
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE- THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH DURING THE
FALL- LAST JULY OUR COUNCIL PUT
FORWARD A PROPOSAL IT WAS MADE
PUBLIC- THAT WAS DESIGNED
SPECIFICALLY FOR ADDRESSING
EQUITY WITHIN THE BRANCH AT THE
TRIAL COURTS. AND IT LAID OUT
THAT- YOU KNOW OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY IS TO GET THOSE LOWER
FUNDED COURTS OP AND SO-
CERTAINLY- IT. SHEIKH
CONSIDERATION HERE AND SHOULD
YOU ARE PASSED THIS AS PROPOSED
IT AND I FULLY EXPECT THAT THE
JEWISH OF HOW. WOULD DOES FIND
CONSIST WITH THE WAY IN WHICH IT
ORIGINALLY PER. WHICH WOULD
THOSE LOWER FUNDED COURTS. SO-
HOW WILL YOU ENSURE THAT THE
COURTS. R. ACTUALLY YOU SEEN-
THE DOLLARS ADEQUATELY AND
MAKING THEM INVESTMENTS AND IN
APPROPRIATE WAYS R. HARI IN AB
WHERE DO WE HAVE A MEASURE OF
HOW WE'RE GONNA BE TRACKING
SUCCESS- AND ENSURING THAT WE
INCREASE ACCESS TO JUSTICE FOR
COURT USERS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND WE DO HAVE- WE HAVE-
LEGISLATIVELY MANDATED ARE
REPORTING AS FAR AS- STANDARDS
FOR COURTS AND THAT THAT
REPUBLICANS HAVE. REALLY THAT'S
ONE VEHICLE WHICH WE CAN.
MEASURE COURTS AND HOW THERE ARE
MOVING FORWARD- IT THE REALITY
IS MANY COURT BRING DIFFERENT
PLACES RIGHT NOW WITH DIFFERENT
NEEDS AND- YOU KNOW WE
APPRECIATE THE FLEXIBILITY THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS GIVEN.
COURSE AND ASK- WITH REGARD TO
DISCRETIONARY FUNDS TO MAKE SURE
WE ARE ADDRESSING PUBLIC- IT AS
BEST NEEDED IN THOSE AREAS. ARE
I KNOW OUR COURTS TALKING ABOUT
STANDARD. HOURS AND DAYS- OPEN
TO THE PUBLIC- THERE IS A REAL
CHALLENGE WITH REGARD TO YOUR
RETAINING STAFF- AND CREASING
STAFFING LEVELS QUITE FRANKLY
AND I EXPECT THAT. YOU ARE A
HIGH PRIORITY THERE TO ABOUT- SO
I JUST I GUESS YOU KNOW- WE KEEP
HEARING ABOUT THE SCRIPT A CEASE
AND IN DIFFERENT COURTS AND SOUL
WHY. WANT TO BE COMFORTABLE WITH
THE IDEA FLEXIBILITY IN LETTING
COURTS DECIDE THAT IT'S ON TO
MAKE SURE THAT AT THE BACK AND
WE HAVE SOME REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY- TO THAT HE-
DISCREPANCIES ARE ARE
JUSTIFIABLE IF THEY EXIST
BECAUSE MAYBE THERE'S DIFFERENT.
WITHOUT WITH THE PANDEMIC
DIFFERENT. DIFFERENT SEARCHES IN
DIFFERENT AREAS BUT- I DO THINK
WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT A LITTLE
BIT BETTER HOW WE'RE GONNA MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S NOT THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY. I'M SURE WE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH STAFF ON
ABSOLUTELY. MR STYLE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WOULD LIKE TO
UNDERSCORE WHAT YOU JUST SAID. I
THINK WE'VE WE'VE SEEN AND SORT
OF UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU JUST
COUNCIL WANTS TO DO WITH THIS
MONEY. BUT WE HAVE STRUGGLED IN
THE PASSING GETTING REPORTING.
AND CLARITY ON ON HOW MONEY IS
TO BE SPENT. FROM THIS COMMITTEE
STANDPOINT THIS EQUITY FUNDING I
THINK IS VERY IMPORTANT. BUT WE
NEED TO UNDERSTAND. WHAT THE
PLAN IS. WHAT THE METRICS ARE.
AND ON AN ONGOING BASIS
REPORTING SPECIFICALLY WITH THIS
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS.
APPROPRIATE APPLICATION
EQUITABLE APPLICATION. ENDS I
ALSO THINK THAT SOMETHING. THAT
THIS COMMITTEE THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE ON THE COURSE.
YOU HAVE FIFTY EIGHT SEPARATE
SOMETIMES LITTLE FIEFDOMS. AND
THAT CAUSES SOME SOME CONCERN
AND INCONSISTENCIES. IN
APPLICATION AND IMPLEMENTATION
COURT BY COURTS. IF WE'RE GOING
TO BE COMING UP WITH A HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS. FOR THIS EQUITY
I THINK WHAT WE WHAT THINGS WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE IS THAT WE'RE
LIFTING UP. COURTS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING WITH WHATEVER IT IS
THAT THEY'RE STRUGGLING WITH BUT
ALSO INSISTING THAT THERE ARE
THERE THERE ARE ENOUGH
CONSISTENCIES AMONG ALL THE
COURTS SO THAT ANYONE PRACTICING
BEFORE COURT FOR ANYONE BEING
CALLED IN FRONT OF THE COURT.
HAS THE BEST CHANCE POSSIBLE OF
UNDERSTANDING WHAT'S HAPPENING
AND WHY SO. GETTING THE PLAN
ENSURING THAT THERE'S ADEQUATE
REPORTING AND DRIVING'S BETTER
CONSISTENCY AMONG THE COURTS
WOULD CERTAINLY BE SOME OF I
THINK THIS COMMITTEES GOALS AS
WE MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU
MEMBER STEP ON IT AND WE ARE IN
AGREEMENT THERE WITH REGARD TO
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT. PUBLIC FUNDS ARE
ARE ARE SPENT APPROPRIATELY
ABSOLUTELY AND- YEAH WE'RE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE
THERE- AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT.
THE COURT FAMILIES ALSO YOU KNOW
LOOKING AT THIS VERY SAME
ISSUES- JUDGE CENTER. MR
HARRIGAN BOB OUR- COURT
LEADERSHIP AND I ALSO ARE
INVOLVED IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY THE
STANDARDS. OF WORK SYSTEM IT'S
WORKING OUT RIGHT NOW. OKAY
THANK YOU'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN
THAT ARE CLOSE COURT
CONSTRUCTION PROPOSAL.
IS THE DIRECTOR OF FACILITIES
SERVICES FOR THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. SHARE THE MEDICARE BILL
MCCORMICK DIRECTOR OF FACILITIES
SERVICES IT IS A COUNCIL- WE
HAVE THREE- PROPOSALS BEFORE YOU
TODAY- A FORTY MILLION DOLLAR
BACKFIELD THE COR CONSTRUCTION-
FUND UP FIFTEEN POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR ONGOING FOR
CRITICAL BUILDING REPAIRS THE
TRIAL COURTS AND TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS. APPLE
PROJECT REQUESTS FOR TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE INCLUDE CONTINUING
BASIS FOR TRIAL COURT PROJECT IN
MENDOCINO BUTTE AND ST BERNARD
DINO AND FIVE NEW START CAPITAL
PROJECTS FOR THE TRIAL COURT'S
IN SOLANA FRESNO PLUMAS SAN LUIS
OBISPO AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
THE FACILITY PROGRAM REQUEST
CONSIDERATION FOR AN ONGOING
INCREASE TO THE TRIAL COURT
CAPITOL BUILDING REPAIR BUNDY.
HAS NO ADJUSTMENTS HAVE BEEN
MADE TO THIS BUDGET SINCE TWENTY
FOURTEEN THE HEARING TO AGENDA
INCLUDES A SUMMARY OF THESE
REQUEST OF THE STATUS OF THE
ONGOING CAPITAL PROGRAM
AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION OR TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT. YES
MANAGER THE PAST TWO OF THIS IS
LIKE OF EUROVISION JUDICIAL
COUNCIL IS BRIEFLY COMMENT ON
THE NEED FOR THE FORTY MILLION
DOLLAR BACKLOG IN THE STATE
COURT FACILITIES CONSTRUCTION
FONG. I'M IT IS ONE OF FUNDS ITS
HAD A DECLINING REVENUE I'M OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL ON FISCAL YEARS
AND- IN ORDER TO ENSURE ITS
SOLVENCY AND TO. ADDRESS DEBT
SERVICE STAFF COMPLEMENT THE
SORT OF MODIFICATIONS A- NOW
BACK OF THE PAST FORTY MILLION.
IS PROPOSED- AS ALWAYS-
DEFINITELY IS A SOUL. I LOOK
FORWARD TO SECURE SUPPORT TO
MAINTAIN. SOLVENCY OF THIS
CRITICAL CONSTRUCTION FUND. BUT
HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. I NEED ONLY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
WE WENT OUT FOR THE COMMITTEE
THAT- THIS IS THIS FIND IS ONE
OF THOSE FUNDS THAT RECEIVES-
LEVINE- OFF LINE AS WELL- COULD
PROVE ANY BE REVENUE AS WELL AS
OTHER REVENUES AND SO IT'S GOING
TO FACTOR INTO YOUR DISCUSSION
AND- ON THE NEXT ISSUE ITEM AS
WELL AS KIND OF PRIOR
CONVERSATIONS YOU HAD- ARE
CONCERNED SPECIFICALLY WITH THIS
FIND AND THIS MEANS PROPOSALS IS
THAT THERE IS A LONG TERM
SOLVENCY ISSUE IN THIS
CONTRACTION FUND THAT IS NOT.
PROPOSED TO BE ADDRESSED AND THE
SOLVENCY WILL LIKELY REQUIRE
SIGNIFICANT FUND RESOURCES ON AN
ONGOING BASIS. TO PAY FOR THE%
DEBT SERVICE FOR ALREADY
COMPLETED COURTHOUSES AND SO DO
IN ORDER TO PERMANENTLY ADDRESS
THE LONG TERM SOLVENCY OF THIS
CONSTRUCTION ACCOUNT WE ACTUALLY
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHIFT FULL RESPONSIBILITY FOR
TRIAL COURT CONSTRUCTION TO THE
GENERAL FUND BY SHIFTING OFF
FINANCING OBLIGATIONS OVER TO
THE GENERAL FUND. APPROPRIATING
GENERAL FUND TO MAINTAIN SUPPORT
FOR EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY FUNDED- THROUGH THIS
ACCOUNT AND THEN DEPOSITING ALL
REVENUES THAT WOULD HAVE
OTHERWISE BEEN DEPOSITED INTO
THIS ACCOUNT INTO THE GENERAL
FUND INSTEAD SO THEY'RE STILL
AVAILABLE TO OFFSET THOSE COSTS
THAT GOT SHIFTED. AND SO THIS
APPROACH WOULD ENSURE THAT ALL
CONSTRUCTION RELATED OBLIGATIONS
ARE FULLY ACCOUNTED FOR AND
CONSIDER WHEN WE'RE EVALUATING
THE STATE'S OVERALL PHYSICAL
CONDITION AND DETERMINING
GENERAL FUND PRIORITIES.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER FULL
RESPONSIBILITY IS SHIFTED OVER
TO THE GENERAL FUND WE DO
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATE FUNDING FOR FACILITY
RELATED PROJECTS BASED ON ITS
GENERAL FUND PRIORITIES. IF IT
IS A PRIORITY THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER ADDITIONAL ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR PORT FACILITY
PROJECTS SUCH AS FOR PHILLY
MODIFICATION OR EFERRED
MAINTENANCE. AS THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH HAS IDENTIFIED
SIGNIFICANT FACILITY NEEDS AND
THIS TYPE OF SPENDING IS
EXCLUDABLE UNDER SAL. THANK YOU
CAN LEAVE HAPPY HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. JUST A REMINDER PARTNER
FINANCE- THE IMMINENT INSOLVENCY
AT THE STATE COURT FACILITIES
CONSTRUCTION FUND IS ONE
MANIFESTATION OF A BROADER
PROBLEM RELATED TO REDUCE
REVENUES FOR NOT ONLY THIS FUND.
ANOTHER RECIPIENT FUNDS
INCLUDING COURTS SPECIAL FUNDS
THEREFORE ANY WE BELIEVE ANY
SOLUTION FOR THIS FUND SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED IN A BROADER CONTEXT
OF HOW TO ADDRESS INTENDED
IMPENDING SOLVENCY ISSUES. FOR
OTHER COURTS SPECIAL FUNDS FOR
INSTANCE OTHER POTENTIAL
SOLUTIONS KICKED COULD INCLUDE
STOPPING TRANSFERS OF RESOURCES
TO AND FROM OR SPECIAL FUNDS
MOVING CERTAIN EXPENDITURES FROM
EACH SPECIAL GOING TO THE
GENERAL FUND. OR GENERAL FUND
CONSOLIDATION IN GENERAL I FOR
NOW OUR PLAN IS TO SET ASIDE
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE. TO BACK FOR THE
STATE OR BECAUSE OF THESE
CONSTRUCTION BY ALLOWING FOR THE
THUNDER MADE SOLVENT WITHOUT
REDUCING SERVICE LEVELS IN THE
BUDGET YEAR WELL WE DEVELOP A
PERMANENT SOLUTION TO PASS
INSOLVENCY FOR ONLY THIS FUND.
BUT OTHERS INCLUDING THE
IMPROVEMENT. AND MODERNIZATION
WHAT. THANK YOU HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. SO I WANT TO GO BACK
TO THE SAW ISSUE- AND THE L. A.
OLD. THROUGHOUT A NUMBER OF TWO
HUNDRED MILLION A YEAR FOR TEN
YEARS US THE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS- THAT THAT WE ARE GOING
TO BE HAVING PROBLEMS WITH.
EITHER THE DEPARTMENT THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHY ARE WE
NOT TRYING TO THINK MORE LONG
TERM SOLUTION ESPECIALLY SENSE
THESE FUNDS WOULD QUALIFY TO BE
SELL EXCLUDABLE EXPENSES. I JUST
TO REMIND FINANCED THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION I'M IT IS FAR AS
ALL OF THE EXPENDITURES BEING
CONSIDERED SALAS GLOBAL I WOULD
HAVE TO TAKE ANOTHER LOOK AT
THAT JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
IS THE CASE- AS FAR AS THAT THE
STATE COURT FACILITIES
CONSTRUCTION FUND IT IS A PLAN
THAT. WE HAVE BEEN MONITORING
AND LAST YEAR WE GET ACTUALLY
CONSOLIDATED THE TWO CORE
CONSTRUCTION ON TO THE STATE
CORPORATE SO HE'S CONSTRUCTION
BUT ANY IMMEDIATE AND CRITICAL
NEEDS ACCOUNT UP TO ALLOW FOR
SOLVENCY IN THE- A CURRENT YOUR-
CURRENTLY. AND THEN THE BUT
YOU'RE TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE SO I'M MOVING FORWARD WITH
OUR PLAN IS TO DO IS TO SET
ASIDE THE FUNDING FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR AND THEN ONCE WE MOVE
FORWARD INTO THE FOLLOWING YEAR
CONSIDER A SOLUTION. THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE MOVING OUT OF
THIS NETWORK FACILITIES
CONSTRUCTION FUND INTO THE
GENERAL FUND- IN THE FUTURE- AS
WE MOVE FORWARD- IN IN THE
CURRENT YEAR WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
CONSISTENTLY MONITOR REVENUES
THAT THIS COULD IMPROVE OUR
KITCHEN THERE COULD BE LAST.
REVENUE NEEDED BUT WE WANTED TO
DEFER THIS OPTION SO WE CAN HAVE
A COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION UNTIL
JUST THIS ISSUE POTENTIALLY. IN
THE FALL. AND YOU. MAY IN YOUR
PURSE IT DEPARTMENT TO FIND YOU
BRIEFLY MENTIONING YOUR-
PRESENTATION- AS A POSSIBILITY
CONSIDERING CONVERTING THE
FUNDING TO THE GENERAL FUND
WHICH IS WHAT THE L. A- TALKED
ABOUT IS SOMETHING THAT IS
SERIOUSLY BEING CONSIDERED JUST.
SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE MENTIONING
AS A POSSIBILITY. I MEAN WORKING
SINGLE SOLUTIONS ASK NICELY A
POINT OUT THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
BALANCE THERE- WHICH IT IT IS AN
OPTION TO ADDRESS THE GENERAL
FUND IT'S NOT JUST WHO
DEPARTMENTS FINANCE SAYING THAT
IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD.
HAVE TO LOOK INTO IT FURTHER. IT
JUST SEEMS THAT GIVE AN IDEA OF
PRESIDENTE SURPLUS THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW THAT THIS WOULD BE THE
TIME TO FOCUS ON. NOT JUST
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY
THREE BUT THE LONG TERM-
PROJECTIONS AND THE SHORTCOMINGS
THAT WEHAVE- VERSUS AT A FUTURE
WITH THAT'S NOT GUARANTEED. TO
BE TO SEE THESE DISPENSED AGAIN.
ON INTO FEELS LIKE A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY FOR US. MR STONE.
THANK YOU BATUM CHAIR IT ENDS
THIS PROPOSAL A LOT OF WAYS JUST
KINDA KICKED THAT CAN DOWN THE
ROAD AND IF WE JUST. GET THE
THIS ACCOUNT SOLVENTS FOR NOW
THEN. THAT'S GOING TO LEAVE US
WITH SIGNIFICANT QUESTIONS DOWN
THE ROAD I WOULD FRANKLY RATHER
SEE US COME UP WITH A BROADER
PLAN FOR HOW WE ADDRESS.
FACILITIES NEEDS NOW AND ON
GOING AND THAT WOULD PUT INTO
CONTEXT EXACTLY. THE BROADER
PICTURE THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
AND REMEMBER THAT WHAT OF THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH BUDGET EVEN IF
YOU LOOK AT THE PREVIOUS ACTION
ITEM THE CERTAINLY THE NEXT ITEM
IT'S REALLY BUILT ON. FINES AND
FEES IN ORDER TO MAKE ENDS MEET
AND- INSTEAD OF JUST REDUCING
SOME OF THESE FINES AND FEES WE
HAVE TO HAVE A PLAN FOR GETTING
RID OF THESE FINES AND FEES
THEIR INEQUITABLE IT IS THE
WRONG WAY. TO BUILD THESE
BUDGETS AND AN ACTUAL LIKE THIS
GIVES THE LEGISLATURE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT ALL THE
CONSTRUCTION PROPOSALS ARE SOME
OF THESE HAVE BEEN LANGUISHING
FOR DECADES. AND PRIORITIES THAT
WERE SET DECADES AGO MAY NOT BE
PRIORITIES NOW SO IF THIS WERE
TO COME IN THE GENERAL FUND
WHICH I THINK IS A LOT OF ONE
GOAL. AND A PLAN TO DO THAT
WOULD GIVE US MUCH MORE
VISIBILITY INTO WHAT THEY'RE
CONSTRUCTION NEEDS ARE. BE ABLE
TO LEVERAGE MORE BROADLY. THE
STATE'S. ABILITY TO LEVERAGE
FIVE IT'S FINANCES. MANAGE SOME
OF THIS DEBT AND HAVE US I DON'T
KNOW THE SOLUTION SENT SHUDDERS
DOWN THE SPINES OF EVERYBODY
JUDICIAL COUNCIL BUT HAVE THE
LEGISLATURE MORE INVOLVED IN
DECISIONS ABOUT. WHERE COURT
CONSTRUCTION IS HAPPENING WHERE
THE DEMOGRAPHICS ARE DRIVING
SOME OF THESE DCISIONS AS
OPPOSED TO JUST SHORING UP FUNDS
AND GOING WITH SOME SOME
OUTDATED. PRIORITIES SO THIS
SHIFT I THINK IT'S SOMETHING WE
COULD REALLY START OUT NOW WE DO
HAVE THE MONEY TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE SOME OF THESE INVESTMENTS
AND I THINK THIS LEGISLATURE IS
VERY INTERESTED. IN SOLVING. THE
ISSUES MORE BROADLY ABOUT FINES
AND FEES BUT ALSO GETTING ITS
HANDS ARE. MORE FIRMLY AROUND
WHERE SOME OF THIS MONEY IS
BEING SPENT WHITES BEING SPENT
WHAT SOME OF THESE PROJECTS ARE
AND CLEARLY UNDERSTANDING WHERE
THE NEED IS SO I THINK THAT
PROPOSAL IS SOMETHING WE
DEFINITELY SHOULD BE LOOKING AND
WORKING ON AND I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE. A PATH TOWARDS MOVING TO
PUT THESE CONSTRUCTION FUNDS
INTO THE GENERAL FUND SO THAT WE
HAVE MORE DIRECT ACCESS TO BE
ABLE TO MANAGE THOSE AND HELP
DIRECT PRIORITIES. MADAM CHAIR I
MADE THIS IS WAS LACK OF THE
RICHMOND COUNCIL. AND THAT- AND
JUST WANT TO DESCRIBE JUST
BRIEFLY ABOUT THE FISCAL
ORGANIZATION. THAT S. YES YOU
HAVE TO USE THE FUND THAT SAID
GOOD QUESTION ABOUT THE SOLVENCY
IT'S NOT PAY FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
AND NEW. PROJECTS AND SO THIS IS
VERY FUNDING THE EXISTING
OBLIGATIONS OF THAT PARTICULAR
FUND- ARE NOW FUTURE NEEDS FOR-
INSTRUCTION ALONG HAVE A MISSED
MCCORMICK TALK ABOUT THE- THE
RESET- WE'VE- THROUGH. ONE BUT
THAT IS NOW THE GENERAL FUND IS
THE. THE FUNDING SOURCE FOR
FUTURE. AND FUTURE. OPTIONS ARE
GONNA TAKE A TO DIRECTOR- THE
PROJECT ABOUT OUR RECENT READ
LEGISLATIVELY MAN- REPORTERS OF
OUR CONSTRUCTION. OKAY THANK YOU
LIKABLE ABOUT CAR DIRECTOR
PRISCILLA SERVICES IN TWENTY
NINETEEN WE BROUGHT THE
pREPORT- AT. REASSESSED ALL OF
OUR CAPITAL PROJECT NEEDS WE-
BASICALLY PULLED EVERY SINGLE-
OF THE EVERYONE OF THE FIFTY
EIGHT COURTS WE DEVELOPED A
COURT FACILITIES PLAN SPECIFIC
TO EACH COURT JURISDICTION. AND
THEN AT A COMPREHENSIVE
METHODOLOGY THAT WE WENT THROUGH
TO RANK THESE PROJECTS TO
PRIORITIZE THEM- WE ENDED UP
WITH EIGHTY PROJECTS- IN TWENTY
NINETEEN DOLLARS IT WAS ABOUT
THIRTEEN POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF MEAT. AND WE'RE
HAVE INCORPORATED THAT STATEWIDE
LIST AS OUR FIVE YEAR
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN. IT HAVE
BEEN- BEEN WORKING DOWN THAT
LIST- IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
THE FUNDING SOURCES DID SHIFT
FROM- THE. IMMEDIATE- DICKEL
NEED ACCOUNT TO GENERAL FUND
WHICH HAS- IS. THE FUNDING-
SOURCES FOR THE CAPITAL PROJECTS
BUT THEY HAVE BEEN PRIORITIZED-
VERY METHODICALLY AND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS. MR JOHNSON MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU- I'M KINDA CURIOUS ABOUT OUR
I WAS CHAIR IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
AND I DO REMEMBER THE THESE
LISTS AND- I THINK AT THE TIME-
DURING THE REALLY BAD ECONOMIC
TIMES THE LEGISLATURE TOOK QUITE
A BIT OF YOU TOOK A HAIR CUT TO
HELP BALANCE THE BUDGET. IT WAS
A SIGNIFICANT. SIGNIFICANT HAIR
CUT AT ALL IT AT THE TIME- THE
GOVERNOR. BASICALLY HELP BALANCE
THE BUDGET BY USING THIS AND I'M
I'M NOT SURE IF WE EVER. I TRY
TO GET AS MUCH LARGER CHINESE
MUCH MONEY BACK INTO
CONSTRUCTION FUNDS BUT PART OF
PART OF MY- MY DILEMMA WAS-
HAVING JUDGES. AND LAWYERS DO
CONSTRUCTION- THAT WHEN I WAS
DIRECTOR OF ASSET MANAGEMENT FOR
THE CITY WHEN YOU HAD- POLICE
AND FIRE AND LIBRARIANS HANDLING
CONSTRUCTION. OF MOST THE TIMES
THEY WERE OVER BUDGET AND THEY
NEVER MET THE TIME LIMIT THAT
THEY GAVE WHEN THEY WOULD
COMPLETE THE PROJECT WHICH WAS
TOTALLY IN AN EFFICIENT AND IN
SOME CASES. MANAGERS HAD. BOB
OFFICERS LARGER THAN COUNCIL
OFFICES AND MAYOR'S OFFICES- IS
EXTREMELY WASTE OF MONEY BUT
ONCE WE GOT PUBLIC WORKS
ENGINEERING INVOLVED AND PUT. A
PUBLIC FOR ENGINEERS AND PROJECT
MANAGERS INVOLVED WE HAVE TO GET
IT ON. IN IN SOME KIND OF- UNDER
CONTROL AND SO ARE PROJECTS FROM
THAT POINT ON TO WORK ON TIME
AND ON BUDGET. AND SO MY FIRST
QUESTION IS. I'M LOOKING AT
THESE NUMBERS. ABOUT THE
APPROVED PROJECT BUDGET BUT IT
DOESN'T GIVE YOU WHAT THE
ORIGINAL. COSTS IT WAS SO I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT IN ACOSTA
MATERIALS GOING UP- YEAH YEAH
YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE PLACE A LOT
OF THE BLAME ON REDUCE REVENUES
BUT WHAT ABOUT INCREASE COSTS
OVER A PERIOD OF TIME- WITH-
EMBARGOES WITH. THE FACT THAT WE
CAN'T MOVE GOODS AND SERVICES
OUT OF THE PORT ALL OF THAT HAS
A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON ON YOUR
CONSTRUCTION BOTTOM LINE- AND I
DON'T. IT'S NOT REALLY
REFLECTED. IN THIS- RIGHT NOW- I
GUESS AS PART OF THE- AS PART OF
YOUR PROBLEM OF HAVING SOMEONE.
HAS BEEN HERE FOR MORE THAN SIX
YEARS US OWNERS BEEN HERE NOW
FOR TEN YEARS ACTUALLY REMEMBER
WHEN. THESE COSTS WERE A LOT
DIFFERENT AND SO IF THERE'S A
WAY YOU CAN GET TO MY OFFICE
WITH THE ORIGINAL COST WITH THE-
YOU KNOW WHAT IS THE DELTA
BETWEEN WHAT YOU RAISING
DAUGHTERS WOULD COST AND HOW
ITS- HOUSING GROUND. BUT MOST
IMPORTANT WHAT WAS THAT WAS THE
REASON FOR THAT- BECAUSE AS THE
MEMBERS ARE HERE ST NOW A WE'RE
LOOKING AT THINGS THAT AT THE
TIME RIGHT NOW. BUT WE MAY GO UP
TO TWO BILLION DOLLARS OVER TEN
YEARS WELL LIKE I COULD PROBABLY
SAFELY SAY MOST PEOPLE HERE ALL
OF US WILL BE GONE. AND WILL
HAVE THE SAME DANCE AGAIN. WHERE
YOU MAY BE ASKING FOR FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS BUT THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE. WON'T BE HERE AND
NOBODY ASKING FOR MORE MONEY AND
THIS JUST SEEMS TO KEEP GOING ON
AND ON AND ON. LUCKILY MOST OF
THE STATE'S. OR WHEN MOST OF US
. TERM OUT SEPT YOU GOT SOME-
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX TWENTY
EIGHT. BUT EVEN THEN IT TWENTY
FOUR YOU COULD COME BACK AND SAY
WE NEED ANOTHER FOUR YEARS OF
FIVE YEARS AND SO I'M NOT. ONE
OF THEM MAKE SURE THAT WHATEVER
THE ORIGINAL ESTIMATE WAS THAT
YOU'RE STILL WITHIN THAT AND IF
YOU'RE NOT WHETHER THOSE REASONS
SO WE CAN PLAN TEN YEARS FROM
NOW TO- FOR ANY THING THAT COULD
COME UP. AND INTO- I'M- I THINK
WE SHOULD BRING IT IN. AND THAT
CAPACITY FOR JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO
HANDLE THIS AND GET SOME ACTUAL
CONSTRUCTION PROFESSIONALS. TO
BE ON TOP OF THIS- WE HIRE ALL
PROJECT MANAGERS. ALMOST LIKE
INSPECTOR GENERAL TO OVERSEE
THESE CONSTRUCTION PROJECT
SHOULD HE COME IN ON TIME AND ON
BUDGET AND GIVE THE LEGISLATURE
SOME COMFORT. THAT THESE THAT
THESE PROJECTS ARE BEING DONE
ACCORDING TO OUR SPECIFICATIONS
OF WHAT WE ARE ALLOCATING THE
MONEY FOR AND THAT WEEK THAT THE
MONIES ARE SPENT APPROPRIATELY.
SO I WROTE THAT COULD BE THAT
COULD BE DONE. I'M CERTAINLY
THAT'S A VERY GOOD POINT ABOUT-
CONSTRUCTION ESCALATION AS- THE-
CALIFORNIA CONSTRUCTION INC
INDEX HAS BEEN RUNNING UITE
RAMPANT THE LAST YEAR OR TWO
IT'S UP OVER FIFTEEN PERCENT-
BUT WE DO HAVE A THE- UNIT OF
PROFESSIONALS I AM A LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL MYSELF AND HAVE
BEEN DOING PROJECT MANAGEMENT
FOR THIRTY YEARS- AND I DO HAVE
A QUADRI. OF AT LEAST TWENTY- TO
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE ON STAFF
WHO DO MANAGE THESE PROJECTS- WE
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ANDTHROUGH THE STATE
PUBLIC WORKS FOR TO ENSURE THAT.
OUR PROJECTS- SCOPES SCHEDULES
AND BUDGETS ARE- IN ALIGNMENT
WITH THE APPROPRIATIONS THAT
THEY ARE GRANTED. AND WE DO
ESCALATOR PROJECTS BASED ON
CALIFORNIA CONSTRUCTION INDEX.
JUGGLING OVER T. INDEX BY A LOT
A LITTLE AND DO YOU DO CLAWBACKS
IF THE CONTRACTOR IS NOT
PERFORMING TO THE TO YOUR
STANDARDS TOTALLY SHEER HIGH
STANDARD DO YOU CLAW BACK SOME
OF THAT TAXPAYER MONEY SO THAT
WE CAN EITHER HIRE SOMEBODY ELSE
IS GONNA GET THE JOB DONE
QUICKER FASTER CHEAPER OR I MEAN
WHAT KIND OF CONTROLS DO YOU
HAVE OR DO YOU COME BACK TO US.
AND JUST ASK FOR MORE MONEY. OF
THE WE WATCH OUR BOTTOM LINE
VERY CLOSELY AND- YOUR LIFE THE
CONSTRUCTION AND ESCALATION
SPECIALLY THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC HAS BEEN- PROBLEMATIC
BUT THE MAJORITY OF OUR PROJECTS
HAVE BEEN RUNNING WITHIN BUDGETS
WERE WITHIN THE- APPROPRIATIONS.
WHEN WE'RE UNABLE TO- YEAH WE
DO- VALUE ENGINEERING EXERCISES
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN GET
THESE PROJECTS AWARDED AND- WE
HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN GETTING
THEM DELIVERED ON TIME. OKAY. IT
ALSO BE IMPORTANT FOR THEM TO
DEPARTMENTS TO EXPLAIN HOW THEY
ARE INVOLVED AS PARTNERS WITH
THE LEGISLATURE ON OUR ON OUR
CONSTRUCTION PROGRAM ON THE NET
WE DO FOLLOW THE RULES OR
REGULATIONS AND ALL OTHER STATE
ENTITIES ARE REQUIRED TO- TO
FOLLOW UP TO ENSURE PROJECT
DELIVERY WITHIN SCOPE AND
BUDGET. AND ACCOUNTING FOR THE
FACT THAT THERE ARE NONE. WHAT
THE COSTS ON. BYE BYE DO YOU
HAVE TO DISCUSS THE POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU LUCK OCCURRING
ARRIVING OR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THAT'S OKAY IF I ADDRESS
THAT QUESTION AS WELL. BUT THANK
YOU M. JUDICIAL BRANCH HAS SEEN
SOME INFLATION INCREASES HOWEVER
THEY ARE IN LINE WITH WHAT WE'RE
SEEING FOR CONSTRUCTION
INFLATION ACROSS THE STATE IN
LINE I WOULD SAY AT OR BELOW SO
I THINK JUDICIAL BRANCHES DONE A
REALLY GOOD JOB KEEPING THEIR
PROJECTS WITHIN BUDGET AND THERE
IS A PROCESS THROUGH THE
CATHOLIC PROCESS. WHERE WE CAN
AUGMENT UP 220% WHICH TO CENTRAL
ST PUBLIC WORKS BOARD. WE HAVE
TAPPED INTO THAT A COUPLE TIMES
BUT NOT EXTENSIVELY. AND OUTSIDE
OF THAT WE HAVE A FIVE YEAR PLAN
WHICH IS PROPOSED THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WHICH SHOWS. OF THAT
THIRTEEN POINT TWO BILLION THAT
WAS PART OF THE ORIGINAL TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN REASSESSMENT.
HOW MANY OF THOSE WE PLAN ON
TACKLING EACH YEAR AND THOSE
COSTS ARE UPDATED IN THE FIVE
YEAR PLANS YOU CAN SEE IF WE GET
A PLANNING DOING PROJECT NUMBER
EIGHT FOR EXAMPLE IN YOUR TO.
YOU WOULD SEE WHAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY ESTIMATING THAT
PROJECT TO BE SO OBVIOUSLY THOSE
COSTS WILL INCREASE AS BE
POSTPONED THEM OUT INTO THE
FUTURE BECAUSE THERE IS A NORMAL
INFLATION. INDEX THAT'S BUILT
INTO THAT- AND THEN ALSO THE
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON RIGHT NOW. AND AS A
LEAD ADDRESSED ARE ON SCHEDULE.
AND LOOKING TO BE COMPLETED
SOON. AND DOING OUR BEST TO
ADDRESS THE PROJECTS THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED IN THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN REASSESSMENT IN THE
ORDER OF. PRIORITY THAT THEY
WERE DRESSED AT THAT POINT TIME.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE. ANYONE ELSE. K.
THANK YOU WERE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT ISSUE IT
IS A CIVIL ASSESSMENTS. JUST A
REMINDER FINANCIAL BE PRESENTING
ON THIS ISSUE. IN RECOGNITION OF
THEIR CURRENT CIVIL ASSESSMENT
FEE IS TOO HIGH THE BUDGET
INCLUDES STATUTORY CHANGES TO
REDUCE THE CIVIL ASSESSMENT FROM
THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS AND
INCLUDES FIFTY MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND TO BACK FILL THE
RESULTING LOSS OF REVENUE FOR
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH. FURTHERMORE
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
COMMITTED TO PROVIDING FINANCIAL
RELIEF FOR INDIVIDUALS FROM THE
IMPOSITION OF FINES AND FEES LET
BY STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
MORE SPECIFICALLY TO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT EXPANDED
THE ONLINE ABILITY A PILOT
PROGRAM STATE WHY DO ALLOW
INDIGENT AND LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS TO APPLY ONLINE TO
HAVE THEIR FINES AND FEES FROM
TRAFFIC AND NON TRAFFIC
INFRACTIONS. REDUCED IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THEIR ABILITY TO
PAY- EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
FOR THE BUDGET TRAILER BILL
ELIMINATED ABILITY OF STATE
LOCAL AGENCIES TO IMPOSE CERTAIN
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES FOR CRIMINAL
OFFENSES SUCH AS FEES TO COVER.
THE MEASURE OF COSTS RELATED TO
COLLECTION RESTITUTION AMONG
OTHER TYPES BEGINNING JANUARY
FIRST OF THIS YEAR. AND EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE FROM TWENTY
TWENTY ELIMINATED THE ABILITY OF
STATE LOCAL AGENCIES TO IMPOSE
CERTAIN ADMINISTRATIVE FEES FOR
CRIMINAL OFFENSES SUCH AS FEES
IMPOSED TO RECOVER COSTS RELATED
TO. PROVIDING PUBLIC DEFENSE AND
PROFICIENT TO PROFICIENT I'M
MORE THAN HAPPY. TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE IN THE
HOUSE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
STAFF COMPASS GREAT WITH POLICY
ADVICE CLINIC UC. CA OF LAW WELL
I COMMEND THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSAL TO REDUCE THE CIVIL
ASSESSMENT FROM THREE HUNDRED TO
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS. IT
SIMPLY DOES NOT GO FAR ENOUGH AS
THE MATERIALS IN THE AGENDA NOW
MOST CALIFORNIANS CANNOT AFFORD
TO PAY THE SELF ASSESSMENT.
BECAUSE OF TARGETED POLICING IN
THE OVER SURVEILLANCE OF
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR CIVIL
SUBSTANCE DISPROPORTIONATELY
FALL ON BLACK AND BROWN
CALIFORNIANS AS THEY ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BE PULLED OVER.
TICKETED AND ARRESTED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND OUR RELIANCE ON
CIVIL ASSASSINS IS ALSO- AS A
SOURCE OF REVENUE HAS PROVEN
UNSUSTAINABLE AND COSTLY. EACH
YEAR COURTS CHARGED PEOPLE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN THE SELF ASSESSMENT AND YET
THEY WERE COVER ONLY A SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF WHAT THEY CHARGED%
RANGING FROM 20% IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY 28% AND HUMBOLDT COUNTY.
AND SUCH LOW RATES ARE NOT THE
RESULT OF LACKS COLLECTION
EFFORTS BUT RATHER BECAUSE MOST
PEOPLE WHO ARE ORDERED TO PAY
SIMPLY CANNOT. IN FACT OVER THE
LAST FIVE YEARS REVENUE FROM THE
CIVIL ASSESSMENT HAS DECREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY- AND BY 36%
SPECIFICALLY. SO CIVIL
ASSESSMENTS ARE PERFORMING
CALIFORNIANS AND IT'S PROVING TO
BE AN UNRELIABLE SOURCE OF
REVENUE SO WHAT. PURPOSE IS THE
CIVIL ASSESSMENT SURVEYING. THE
LEGISATURE AUTHORIZED SUPPOSED
ABSENCE FOR FAILURE TO APPEAR
CASES BACK IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIVE I'M AN EXPANDED THAT IN
NINETEEN NINETY SIX TO APPLY TO
FIGURE TO PAY CASES WITH THE
IDEA THAT. THE ABILITY TO IMPOSE
CIVIL ASSESSMENTS WOULD IMPROVE
THE COURT'S ABILITY TO COLLAPSE
ON THESE FINES. BUT CHARGING
PEOPLE ADDITIONAL FEES LIKE
CIVIL ASSESSMENTS DOES NOTHING
TO ENCOURAGE OR SUPPORT SOMEONE
IN PAYING THEIR FACE FINES. IN
FACT THE SURVEY OF PEOPLE WHO
WERE ORDERED TO PAY CIVIL
ASSESSMENTS 73% OF PEOPLE SAID
THEY WEREN'T EVEN AWARE THAT
THEY COULD BE CHARGED A FEE FOR
MISSING A DEADLINE TO PAY OR
APPEARING IN COURT. THIS
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THIS IS A TOOL THAT IS ACTUALLY
INFLUENCING BEHAVIOR. THEY'RE
ALSO MORE HUMANE AND PROVEN
EFFECTIVE TOOLS. LIKE TEXT
MESSAGE REMINDERS TO HELP
INSURE- PEOPLE SHORT COURT OR
CHE AND ALSO AS- OF X. CON. LIKE
AND OF. OUT AND SANCTIONED
COLLECTION. THAT COURTS HAVE
THEIR TO WHICH BLACK OF THE- OR
PAYMENT- WHICH WHY REFER THE
POSH. OF REPEAL A THE FULL
HUNDRED AND BE APPROACHED WITH
SKEPTICISM- I KNOW MR MEAN I'VE
MENTIONED THE ABILITY TO PAY
PILOT PROGRAMS WHICH ARE BUT
SOON TO BE SCALED A STATE WIDE.
BUT THIS PACKAGE STILL LEAVES
ROOM FOR WIDE DISCRETION AND
TURN BIAS PARTICULARLY WHEN WE
KNOW THAT CIVIL ASSESSMENTS
REVENUE WAS MEANT TO FIND TROUT.
OPERATIONS TO FOR EXAMPLE IN
SOLANO COUNTY AFTER A DAY
IMPLEMENTED AN ABILITY TO PAY
PROCESSING SPONSORED SETTLEMENT-
DATA SHOW THAT EVEN IN CASES
WHERE THE COURT HAD DECIDED
EXPLICITLY THAT A PERSON COULD
NOT AFFORD TO PAY. A REDUCED ALL
OTHER FINES AND FEES THE COURT
STILL IMPOSED THE CIVIL
ASSESSMENT IN 97% OF CASES. SO
IN SHORT NOT ONLY OUR CIVIL
ASSESSMENTS NOT MEETING THEIR
INTENDED GOALS ARE HARMFUL AND
COSTLY CALIFORNIANS. UNDER THERE
JUST SIMPLY MORE EQUITABLE AND
HUMANE WAYS TO ENCOURAGE COURT
APPEARANCE IN PAYMENT I DO NOT
PENALIZE POPPY. HM THANK YOU UP
FOR THE- DEPARTMENT OF. HOW DID
HE LAND ON THIS 50% REDUCTION Y.
ENTRE FIFTY S. IS THAT. DO YOU
HAVE A RESEARCHER SCIENCE
TELLING US THAT. SOMEONE IS
PERSONABLE TO PAY A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLARS VERSUS THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. HI THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION NOT JUST YOUR
ONLINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
HELLO WE FEEL THAT A 50%
REDUCTION STRIKES A BALANCE OF
PROVIDING THE IMMEDIATE
DISCREETLY FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
IN A PRESERVE THE VIABILITY OF
THE SENATE CIVIL SESSION BEING
AS IT USED AS A TOOL TO KEEP
INDIVIDUALS ACCOUNTABLE TO
ENSURE THAT THEY SHOW UP FOR
THEIR COURT PROCEEDINGS. AND PAY
THEIR FINES I THOUGHT I'D ALSO
LIKE TO ADD THAT THE SIMPLE
ASSESSMENT IS USED AS A TOOL
INSTEAD OF MORE INTRUSIVE
ACTIONS SUCH AS THE ISSUANCE OF
BENCH WARRANTS WHICH-
DENATURATION PRACTICALLY DOESN'T
WANT TO REVERT BACK TO. IN
ADDITION I ALSO LIKE TO ADD THAT
WE HAVE THE DESTRUCTION HAS
CONSIDERED THE OTHER
ALTERNATIVES- REFERENCE BY MR
BUSH SPOKE ABOUT THE UNUSUAL TO
BUY EXTENSION AS WELL AS- USING
OTHER FORMS OF WAGE GARNISHMENT
BANK LEVEES YOU KNOW AS WE AS WE
CONSIDERED- GOING WITH THE
APPROACH OF PROBABLY EXTENSION.
WHICH WAS AT THAT PARTY CAN BE
USED BY TRIAL COURTS BUT WE JUST
HAVE CONCERNS THAT THIS COULD
RESULT IN ACCESS TO JUSTICE
ISSUES BECAUSE REPUBLICANS WHO
ARE NON RESPONSIVE WOULD BE
FOUND GUILTY WITHOUT FORMAL DEAL
JUDICIAL REVIEW. IN THE
DEFENDERS KNOWLEDGE- IT IS FIRST
THE OTHER POTENTIAL TO NEED TO
BE LOOKING TO I THINK WAGE
GARNISHMENT BANK LEVEES- WE
BELIEVE THAT YOU IN GENERAL
DRAFTING INDIVIDUALS COUNT CAN
RESULT OVER DRAFT NECESSITY FEES
WHICH COULD RESULT IN SOME CASES
EQUAL OR EVEN EXCEED MISSILE
ASSESSMENT THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
BE IMPOSED. WE SHOULD ALSO POINT
OUT THAT THIS IS ALREADY AN
OPTION FOR EXCUSE BUT THIS IS
ONLY FOR ONE INDIVIDUALS HAVE
FINANCIAL PENALTIES IF WE
ELIMINATED THE CIVIL ASSESSMENT
WHICH GARNISHMENT BANK LEVIES
CANNOT BE USED BECAUSE THERE
WOULD BE NOT. BE A FINANCIAL
PENALTY O COLLECT ON. SO KEEP
HE DIDN'T ANSWER MY THERE IS HOW
THE FACT THAT THE HAVE POINT
WITH VERY AND THAT GONNA SAY.
HELP LOW INCOME CAN OF I WOULD
SAY THAT- HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS
IS STILL TOO MUCH FOR MANY OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS AND SO WE ARE
BALANCING BUDGETS ON THE BACKS
OF OUR LOWEST INCOME COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THAT WE KNOW ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY TARGETED- BYE
BYE SYSTEM INSISTS AS WE ENTER
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WITH EQUITY AT
THE FOREFRONT OF ALL THE THINGS
WE DO IT IT'S NOT CLEAR WHY WE
ARE SAYING HALF WAYVERSUS JUST
ELIMINATED IT COMPLETELY AND
FINDING A BETTER WAY TO HAVE A
STABLE RESOURCES FOR OUR PORTS
ARE AND HE FOCUSED A LOT OF
ALTERNATIVES BUT- I WILL SAY
THAT ONE OF OUR PANELISTS ARE
ENOUGH WITH THE SOMETHING THAT
WAS REALLY SIMPLE AND A TEXT
MESSAGE. I TO REMIND PEOPLE THAT
THERE'S NOTHING THAT WE NEED TO.
GO TO A- YOU. NEED TO BE- TO- TO
WOREDA THIS AND SO. CAN WE GO
BACK TO MY INITIAL QUESTION HOW
DID YOU COME UP WITH A HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS BEING FAIR AND
REASONABLE. AND WE WANTED TO
PROVIDE FINANCIAL RELIEF- Q.
INDIVIDUALS TO RALLY IN WE HAD
SETTLED ON A 50% REDUCTION FOR
THE CIVIL ASSESSMENT ON. ALSO
WENT WHEN WE'RE WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT REDUCTIONS IN THE
CIVIL ASSESSMENT IS ALSO A
FACTOR ALONGSIDE BROADER
PROGRAMS OUT ONLINE ABILITY TO
PAY EXPANSION- THROUGH USE OF
THE TOOL IN THE FUTURE- WHEN
INDIVIDUALS APPLY FOR ONLINE
ABILITY TO PAY DETERMINATION IT
WILL CONSTITUTE AN APPEARANCE
BOOK WHICH WILL RESTRICT WHICH
WILL FURTHER REDUCE THE NEED FOR
SIMPLE SYSTEM TO BE ISSUED. IF
I'M STRUGGLING FOR SIMPLE THINGS
LIKE. PUTTING GAS IN MY CAR
WHICH IS LESS THAN A HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS I DON'T SEE HOW
50% OF REALLY GIVES A
INDIVIDUALS THAT BELIEVE THAT
THAT YOU ARE. THEY ARE WISHING
TO DO AND SERVE RELIEF IS OUR
GOAL WHY ARE WE NOT WORKING TO
ELIMINATE THIS FEEL TOGETHER AND
COME UP WITH THE MORE STABLE
SOURCE OF REVENUE FOR OUR COURTS. IT'S- YES SIR I THINK YOU CAN
QUESTION I JUST GETTING BACK TO
LOOK TO MY INITIAL COMMENTS IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT BEING A REVENUE
SOURCE IT'S ABOUT HAVING HAVING
SOMETHING THERE WHEN INDIVIDUAL
FAILS TO APPEAR OR FAILS TO PAY
THEIR FINES AS I HAD MENTIONED
WITH THE IF WE POTENTIALLY
REMOVE THE CIVIL ASSESSMENT FEE
THERE ARE MORE INTRUSIVE ACTIONS
THAT COULD BE TAKE THAT COULD
TAKE PLACE. SUCH AS THE ISSUE
WITH THE BENCH WARRANTS FOR ONE
INDIVIDUALS AREN'T HEARING
SUPPORT THAT IS IT BUT FRANKLIN
ACTION WE DO NOT WANT TO OCCUR
AND WE BELIEVE THE CIVIL
ASSESSMENT TO BE LESS INTRUSIVE
THAN THE ISSUE THE TOPIC WENT ST
JUST A REVENUE ISSUE IT'S ALSO A
STRUCTURAL ISSUE OF WHICH REFORM
CHANGE TO TAKE PLACE- THE
ADMINISTRATION IS OPEN TO
LISTENING TO ALTERNATIVES THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS TO BRING UP
I'M ALSO THERE THERE IS WORK
BEING DONE IN A TEXT REMINDER
SPHERE. BUT THAT DOESN'T GET OUT
THE INHERENT ISSUE OF- AREN'T
COMPELLING INDIVIDUALS INTO
COURT LIKE THE TAX IS NOT GOING
TO NECESSARILY REQUIRED THE
INDIVIDUALS. TO SHOW UP TO COURT
ITSELF. IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT THIS
IS COMPELLED TO FEED SOMETHING
COMPELLED THE VIGILS AND I WILL
CALL YOUR TRAIN OF THOUGHT
THOUGH. SO THIS. BUT WHAT YOU'RE
TELLING ME IS ACCURATE THEN WHY
HAVE WE ELIMINATED OTHER
ADMINISTRATIVE CRIMINAL FEES-
AND MOVE FORWARD WITH WITH THAT
. CHECK THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION AGAIN I WOULD MAKE SURE
SHE DOES APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION ON THIS ISSUE I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT THOSE FEES
ARE CHARGED BY. LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND STATE GOVERNMENT THIS FEET
SPECIFICALLY CHARGED BY PORTS
FOR THE SPECIFIC PURPOSE OF WHEN
IT WILL APPEAR OR FAILS TO PAY
OFF. ON IT UNDERSTANDABLY IS
MISS MISS CAMPUS OF BILLY HAS
POINTED OUT THAT THESE FEES DO
YOU HAVE MORE OF AN IMPACT ON
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND THAT
THAT'S WHY WE'RE ONE OF THE
REASONS WE'RE TRYING TO. LOWER
THE FEE- HERE SPECIFICALLY- BUT
BIG BECAUSE HOW THIS FEAT IT IS
DRIVEN ENGINEERS TO COMPEL
INDIVIDUALS TO COME INTO COURT
WE FIND IT POSSIBLE SAYS AND IT
CAN BE LESS INTRUSIVE. THAN
ALTERNATIVES THAT COULD BE
RELIED UPON IF WE GOT RID OF IT.
IF THIS WAS HAS BEEN WE'RE
ELIMINATED THERE COULD BE AND I
I'M NOT SURE HOW TRUMP WORKS. ON
THERE IS JUDICIAL INDEPENDENCE
THEY COULD ISSUE BENCH WARRANTS
TO COMPEL INDIVIDUALS TO GO TO
WANT TO GO. OUT BEFORE. YEAH SO
IT'S MY- THOUGH THE- WE WERE
NOT. A LOT THESE HE SAID SO IT'S
NOT COME IN THE- TO PAY LEVELS
THE GOAL THIS TO BE A THAT IS
THE WORKING AND NEED TO FIGURE
SOMETHING TO. SO I WILL SAY THAT
MAYBE FOR SOME OF US WHO WERE.
IN THE- ADMINISTRATION ARE HERE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS THINGS
MORE PALATABLE THAN THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. BUT WHEN YOU'RE
STRUGGLING TO LIVING OFF OF FIVE
TEN DOLLARS TODAY A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLARS SAYS THE SCREEN
JUST AS IMPOSSIBLE TO FIGURE
OUT. OUT THERE AND SO I DO HOPE
THAT WE FIND A WAY TO BOTH-
ELIMINATED HE'S COMPLETELY FIND
BETTER WAYS TO INCENTIVIZE
INDIVIDUALS SHOW UP. AND THEN
ALSO FIND SOME STABILITY FOR THE
FOR THE REVENUE FOR THE COURTS
WHICH THEY THINK SOMETHING. THAT
THEY WOULD APPRECIATE GIVEN OUR
LAST DISCUSSION- I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND HAND IT OFF TO MICHAEL
IS THE ONE AFTER THAT. THE
EIGHTH THAT'S RIGHT AGREE WITH
YOU THESE ARE SORT OF OUTDATED
UNPROVEN AND HAVE SUCH A
DISPARATE IMPACT THAT. THIS IS
THE TIME WE COULD BE TAKING
BOLDER STEPS TO REALLY ENSURE
THAT WE ARE PROVIDING JUSTICE IN
AN APPROPRIATE MANNER ACROSS THE
BOARD. SO THE I THINK IT IS TIME
TO ELIMINATE THE CITY'S. YEAH
YES IT JUST FEELS THAT. THE
SPEED SEVEN AWAY TO NORMALIZE
SOME OF OUR- A SYSTEM IN OUR
SYSTEM HERE AND NOT BE AWARE
THAT SO I DO HOPE THAT US AS THE
YEAR PROCEED TO FIND A WAY TO
GET MORE CREATIVE AND ELIMINATE
THE SPEAKS IT IS A TOP PRIORITY.
FOR THIS COMMITTEE THIS YEAR.
NOT SEEN THAT IN MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND MOVE
ON TO. OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES IN ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
WHICH IS THE EXPANSION OF ALL
YES. MADAM SURE GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- PRETTY
WICKED MARC ELRICH DIRECTOR OF
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. OF COURSE IS
ONE THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PARTNERSHIP AND THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SIT AND DISCUSS A LITTLE BIT
TODAY ABOUT THE PROPOSALS WE
HAVE IN THE BUDGET BEFORE YOU.
THIS IS A POINTED REMINDER
KALAYEH SERVICE AS THE STATE'S
LEADERSHIP POP DURING ALL MAJOR
EMERGENCIES AND DISASTERS. THIS
INCLUDES RESPONDING TO DIRECTING%
AND COORDINATING THE STATE AND
FEDERAL RESOURCES OF MUTUAL LATE
ASSETS. ACROSS THE REGION TO
SUPPORT THE DIVERSE COMMUNITIES.-ACROSS THE STATE. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT REALLY CALIFORNIA
HAS MOVED INTO A NEW CHAPTER FOR
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AND
DISASTER RESPONSE AND RECOVERY.
EMERGENCIES AND DISASTERS ARE
MORE FREQUENT. COMPLICATED AND
OFTEN INVOLVING MULTIPLE
COUNTIES AND REGIONS. OF THE
STATE AT THE SAME TIME. THE
EVACUATION OR DISPLACEMENT AND
SUBSEQUENT SUPPORT OF PEOPLE
OVER THE COURSE OF DAYS OR WEEKS
HAS BECOME COMMONPLACE. OVER THE
PAST FIVE YEARS THE STATE HAS
EXPERIENCED UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER
OF AMERICAN CHEESE AND DISASTERS
INCLUDING SEVERE DROUGHT.
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES POWER
GRID OUTAGES. EARTHQUAKES
INTENSIVE STORMS FLOODING CIVIL
UNREST AND OF COURSE THE
UNPRECEDENTED CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. IN FACT FIFTEEN OF THE
MOST DESTRUCTIVE FIRES IN THE
STATE'S HISTORY HAVE OCCURRED
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. WITH
SEVEN OF THOSE OCCURRING IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS ALONE. CALIFORNIA
WILL BE RECOVERING FROM THESE
COMPLEX DISASTERS POINTLESS THE
NEXT DECADE WILL CONTINUE TO
RESPOND TO NEW AND FUTURE
DISASTERS. IN FACT THERE IS NO
DAY THAT GOES BY NOW THEY CAL
HELLO YES IS NOT DIRECTLY
RESPONDING TO A NEW EVENT
MANAGING- AN EXISTING OPERATION
OR IS ACTIVELY WORKING WITH ONE
OF OUR COUNTIES OR CITIES ARE
RECOVERING. WELL A PAST ASTOR.
THE SCOPE AND SCALE OF THE NEED
AT- YES AS ROLE HAS EXPANDED
EXPONENTIALLY. BY STAFF RECENTLY
MET WITH THE L. A- TO GET A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
BUDGET GROWTH THEY REPORTED IT
THEIR ANALYSIS. WHILE WE
UNDERSTAND HOW THEY ARRIVED AT
THE 11009% GROWTH IT REPORTED.
WHEN WE ACCOUNT FOR THE ONE TIME
AUGMENTATIONS PROVIDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE OUR ACTUAL PERMIT
GROWTH. AS ACTUALLY BEEN 87% AND
STILL LEAVES A SHORT ON WHAT IS
NEEDED TO MEET THE CHALLENGES OF
TODAY AND IN THE FUTURE. LAST
YEAR WE WERE BEFORE YOU
DISCUSSING THE CHICK CHANGING
AND WORSENING DISASTER
LANDSCAPING CALIFORNIA. AND THE
CHALLENGES WE FACE TOGETHER. YOU
RECOGNIZE THE NEED AND WITH YOUR
SUPPORT WE MADE INVESTMENTS.
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
CREATING A STRONGER HELLO YES
FINANCING IN SHORING UP KEY
AREAS. A DEDICATED RESOURCES
DEDICATING RESOURCES WIKIPEDIA
DISASTER RESPONSE TO RECOVERY
EFFORTS INCLUDING. ESTABLISHING
A PER MINUTE WHAT WE CALL
INCIDENT SUPPORT TEAM. IN THE
STATE OPERATIONS CENTER THIS IS
A FULL TIME. STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER COMMITTED STAFF. AND AN
INCIDENT MANAGEMENT TEAM.
RESPONDED TO THE FIELD TO
SUPPORT OUR REGIONAL OPERATIONS
IN THE COUNTIES. TO MAINTAIN
BETTER SITUATIONAL AWARENESS AND
MORE QUICKLY RESPOND TO AND
SUPPORT OUR COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE. AND IN DOING SO OF
COURSE LESS THAN OUR PREVIOUS
RELIANCE ON REDIRECTING STAFF.
AN OLDER MODEL THAT WAS REALLY
NOT SUSTAINABLE. I TO MEET
TODAY'S DEMANDS. I AND THEN WE
ALSO EXT. OUR RECOVERY. TO
RESTORE- AND RAPIDLY REBUILD
COMMUNITIES DEVASTATED BY
DISASTER. WHETHER FROM FLOOD
EARTHQUAKE OR OTHER NATURAL
HUMAN COST DISASTER AND OF
COURSE WILDFIRES. UP OF WHICH WE
HAVE SEEN EVERY YEAR SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE
CATASTROPHIC IMPACT AND LOSS
FROM WILDFIRE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
IN FACT SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AT LEAST FIFTY
THOUSAND. HOMES HAVE BEEN
DESTROYED BY A WILDFIRE IN OUR
STATE. THESE ARE ALL IN
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE REQUIRED.
OF POST DISASTER SIGNIFICANT-
YES DISASTER RECOVERY ASSISTANCE
. THE RESOURCES YOU SUPPORT LAST
YEAR WERE CRITICAL TO HELP BUILD
A FOUNDATION THAT SET US ON A
PATHWAY TO BETTER RESPOND TO AND
RECOVER FROM WHAT I CALL THE NEW
NORM. WE ARE FACING. THAT WAS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
WE'VE CONTINUE TO REVIEW OUR
CAPABILITIES OVER THE LAST YEAR
HAVE IDENTIFIED ADDITIONAL WE-
REQUIREMENTS. IN THIS VERY
DIVERSE ORGANIZATION THE BILL
ARE COMPREHENSIVE- YES THAT
REFLECTS AND MEETS THE NEEDS OF
OUR STATE. THE PROPOSALS FOR YOU
TODAY NOW FOCUSED ON ENHANCING
CALIFORNIA'S MUTUAL AID SYSTEM.
IN SUPPORT OF OUR COMMUNITIES UP
OUR DISASTER LOGISTICS EFFORT.
AND OUR OVERALL AGENCY SUPPORT
CAPACITY. IN THE- NEXT THREE
PROPOSALS WHICH WERE BEFORE YOU
THE FIRST BEING. INCREASING
SUPPORT CAPACITY THIS IS A
BUDGET. THAT PROPOSES FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND.
FOR MILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDS AND
TWO HUNDRED THIRTEEN THOUSAND
SPECIAL FUNDS. FOR SEVENTY ONE
POSITIONS- ACROSS THE
ORGANIZATION TO INCREASE
ADMINISTRATIVE AND PROGRAM
SUPPORT BY THE DEPARTMENT. THIS
IS A TRUE UP OF CRITICAL AND
NECESSARY POSITIONS THAT PROVIDE
THE CAPACITY CAUGHT THE AUDIENCE
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE ACROSS THE
AGENCY. THESE POSITIONS INCLUDE
FOR EXAMPLE SPECIALIST IN OUR
FINANCIAL OPERATIONS AUDIT TEAM
LEGAL COMMUNICATIONS AND
RESPONSIBLE ITS ACTIONS. AS A
DEPARTMENT THAT IS RESPONSIBLE
HAVE EXPECTS MONTH
RESPONSIBILITIES HAVE EXPANDED.
AT AS SUCH SO HAS THE TREMENDOUS
WORKLOAD REQUIREMENTS IN THESE
AREAS A LOT OF THIS IS ALSO BACK
OFFICE AND SORT OF SUSTAINMENT
CAPABILITIES BURKE HOT IT WOULD
BE OF OUR OPERATIONS. THE SECOND
IS ADDRESSING OUR LOGISTICS
MANAGEMENT WORKLOAD. THE BUDGET
FOR FOUR POINT NINE MILLION
GENERAL FUND TWENTY ONE POSITION
. THE CAPACITY FOR OUR DISASTER
LOGISTICS AND PLANNING BRANCH.
TRANSPORT MASON EXECUTES
LOGISTIC SUPPORT REQUIREMENTS
DURING AND FOLLOWING MAJOR
INCIDENTS EMERGENCIES AND
DISASTERS SUCH AS FOR EXAMPLE
BUILDING AT SUPPORTING
OPERATIONAL STAGING AREAS AND
BASE CAMPS AND MANAGING
COORDINATING AND FACILITATING
THE DELIVERY OF PP ACROSS THE
STATE TO OUR COMMUNITIES TO OUR
SCHOOLS TO OUR- PRIVATE SECTOR
PARTNERS WORK. ESTABLISHING
VACCINATIONS ARE TESTING SITES-
AS THEY DID DURING THE PANDEMIC
OF COURSE SUPPORTING EMERGENCY
SHELTER AND DISASTER HOUSING
CAPABILITIES AFTER ONE OF OUR
COMMUNITY SUFFERS A CATASTROPHIC
LOSS. REALLY THE ONLY THIS
DISASTER LOGISTICS SECTION HAS
BEEN A CRITICAL RESOURCE
CAPABILITY YEAH ARE ALL HAS ITS
MISSION AND WHILE WE S. AS A
WHOLE IT'S BEEN INCREDIBLY BUSY.
THAT THIS ABSOLUTE JUST EXPLODES
I HAS BEEN ONE OF THE BUSIEST
AREAS OF- YES OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS. THE NEXT IS MISSION
TASKING APPROPRIATION. OF
TELLING US IS CURRENTLY
AUTHORIZED TO MISSION TASK OTHER
STATE AGENCIES TO RESPOND TO
EMERGENCIES. THE LEGISLATURE
AUTHORIZED AN EXISTING
APPROPRIATION TO COVER THE COST.
OF THESE DEPARTMENTS WHEN
MISSION PASSED YOU'RE A DECLARED
EMERGENCIES. THE FUND IS DUE TO
EXPIRE AT THE END OF THE FISCAL
YEAR. THE BUDGET INCLUDES TEN
MILLION DOLLARS ONGOING GENERAL
FUND TO PROVIDE FUNDING TO
STATE. ENTITIES BASICALLY WHEN
WE- MISSION CAST THEM FOR COSTS
INCURRED INCURRED. AS A RESULT
OF THE TASKING. SHOULD SEPARATE
THE STATE AGENCY'S RESPONSE
CAPABILITIES WHEN TIME MATTERS
MOST. INCLUDING THOSE NOT
COVERED UNDER A GOVERNOR'S
PROCLAIM STATE OF EMERGENCY.
THIS IS REALLY WHERE WE HAVE A
CRITICAL ASSET CRITICAL OF THAT.
ARE THAT. WE CAN RAPIDLY MOVE A
STATE AGENCY. THE ONLY- RECKON.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE REJECT THIS
MISSION TASKING APPROPRIATION
PROPOSAL GIVEN THAT THERE IS AN
EXISTING PROCESS FOR AUGMENTING
THE DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET. THAT IS
TRUE. I DID IS THE LONG TERM
PROCESS FOR GOING BACK AND AFTER
THE EVENT IS ALL OVER. HOWEVER
THE INTENT OF THIS PROPOSAL IS
TO RESPOND. PROFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY DURING DISASTERS TO
THE CIRCUMSTANCES IMMEDIATELY AT
HAND FOR EXAMPLE THIS FUNDING
COULD BE USED TO TASK OTHER
STATUS USED TO RESPOND TO A FIRE
A TSUNAMI OR OTHER DISASTER
WHERE A FORMAL DISASTER
DECLARATION HAS NOT YET BEEN
MADE. IT COULD ALSO BE UTILIZED
TO SECURE SCARCE RESOURCES THAT
MAY NOT BE AVAILABLE FORBASIC
REASONS THAT DO NOT INVOLVE THE
PARTICULAR DISASTER. FOR EXAMPLE
OVER THE SUMMER CHALLENGES TO
THE FUEL TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
RESULTED IN PROBLEMS IN GETTING
NECESSARY FUEL TO KEEP
FIREFIGHTING AIRCRAFT
OPERATIONAL- YES MISSION PASSED
THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT. TO RESPOND BY
CONNECTING JET. IT'S COULD BE I
CONNECTING JET A FUEL FROM OTHER
SOURCES IN THE STATE. AIR TANKER
BASES SO FIREFIGHTING AIRCRAFT
COULD CONTINUE TO FIGHT THE
FIRES RATHER THAN BE GRANTED AT
A CRITICAL TIME. THESE ARE THE
VARIOUS PROPOSALS THAT ARE IN
FRONT OF THIS TIME AND HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
THANK YOU. SENATOR MEMBERS OF
COMPUTERS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I BELIEVE I'M
NEXT ON THE PANEL IS DEDICATED
PROCEED. YES THANK YOU I'M THE
FIRST I WANTED TO START WITH OUR
OFFICES OVER ARCHING COMMENTS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS ON- ALL OF
THE GOVERNOR'S FOR FIVE
PROPOSALS FOR- WE ASK AS THIS
WILL PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT FOR A
RECOMMENDATION FIND TWO OF THE
THREE SPECIFIC PROPOSALS IN THIS
ITEM ON AS WELL AS OTHER
PROPOSALS A LEADER IN THE H. AND
AT. SO IN TERMS OF OUR OVER
ARCHING COMMENTS. ON B. SUPPORT
THE BASE SUPPORT BUDGET FOR- YES
HAS INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY IN
RECENT YEARS. YOUR AGENDA
SUMMARIZES THIS AND SOME OF
THESE DOCUMENTATIONS ON PAGE
FIFTEEN. AND HE EIGHTEEN
APPEARANCE AND THAT INCLUDES A
CHART FROM OUR REPORT ON THIS
ISSUE. THAT SUMMARIZES THE THREE
CENT INCREASES. WITH ECONOMIC BE
ON THE SUPPORT FOR- WE ASK HAS
ROUGHLY DOUBLED SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN. AB WHICH IT
WAS THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN I YEAR
WAS SORT OF THE FIRST VERY LARGE
WILDFIRE HERE THAT THE STATE
EXPERIENCED. I'M KICKING OFF
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN BACK TO BACK
YEARS AS A HEIGHTENED LEVEL OF
EMERGENCIES. I WAS A LITTLE TOO
UNDER OUR METHODOLOGY FOR
CALCULATING THE INCREASE IN-
YESS THE B. SUPPORT BUDGET WE
SHELL OUT ONE HUNDRED AND 9%
INCREASE FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN TO THE CURRENT YEAR.
I'M ATHLETIC DIRECTOR MENTIONED
AND- WE ASK CALCULATED THAT
THESE AS SAME TIME FRAME USING A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT METHODOLOGY
AND THEY SHOW UP ROUGHLY 90%
INCREASE. ON THE END OF FUNDING-
FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
TO THE CURRENT YEAR AND SO IT
REALLY IN OUR VIEW IS SORT OF
THE METHODOLOGY USED IN THAT
SPECIFIC NUMBER DOESN'T REALLY
MATTER THAT MUCH ON AS- UNDER
BOTH APPROACHES OF LOOKING AT
THIS. AND P. SUPPORT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT HAS ROUGHLY DOUBLED
I'M IN THE LAST. QUARTER SO
YEARS. I ADDITION WE KNOW WE ARE
THE STAFF LEVEL THAT ALSO
INCREASE THE- DURING THE SAME
TIME CREATED. I'M GROWING BY
ABOUT 66% ON THE BOTTOM PROPOSED
BUDGET WOULD FURTHER INCREASE
BASED FUNDING AND STAFFING FOR-
YES. I WE THINK THAT IT'S
REASONABLE TO CONSIDER
INCREASING THE STATE'S EMERGENCY
RESPONSE CAPACITY ANALYTE AT THE
HEIGHTENED LEVEL OF EMERGENCIES
THE STATE HAS SEEN IN RECENT
YEARS. I'M AND THE POSSIBILITY
THAT THIS HEIGHTENED LEVEL OF
EMERGENCIES CONTINUES INTO THE
FUTURE I'M HOWEVER WE FIND THE
L. YES MAY NOT BE DOING SO IN
THE MOST STRATEGIC MANNER. FIRST
EVERY ASPECT THE STOCKING PLAN
AND SO THE DEPARTMENT STAFFING
NEEDS IN THE NEAR TERM AND
LONGER TERM AND CLEAR. THE
ABSENCE OF CLEARLY IDENTIFIED
STAFFING NEEDS I'VE BEEN IN THE
DEPARTMENT REQUESTING POSITIONS
FOR SIMILAR FUNCTIONS EACH YEAR.
I'M FOR EXAMPLE THAT APARTMENT
HI I'M HAS REQUESTED POSITIONS
FIGHTING OVER TIME FOR ITS
EMPLOYEES AND NEEDING MORE STAFF
AND THEN. AND THEN THEN THE NEXT
YEAR YOU'RE AFTER REQUESTING
OPPOSITION FOR AT THE SAME
RESOURCE FOR THIS AFTER THIS
WITH THE SAME RATIONALE THIRTY
INDICATING THAT PRIOR REQUEST
MAY NOT HAVE BEEN. SUFFICIENT TO
ADDRESS THEIR NEEDS. HI WHICH
RAISES QUESTIONS ABOUT THESE
CURRENT REQUESTS. I'M A FURTHER
WE FIND THE- YES IS PROPOSALS
ARE NOT TIED TO ANY SPECIFIC
EMERGENCY RESPONSABLES OR
OBJECTIVES WHICH MAKES IT
DIFFICULT TO ASSESS THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THESE
PROPOSALS. AND THE EXTENT TO
WHICH THEY WILL ENHANCE THE
STATE'S EMERGENCY RESPONSE
CAPACITY ARE WE WOULDN'T KNOW
THAT THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRED
YES I IN CONJUNCTION WITH CAL
FIRE TO. CONDUCT AN ASSESSMENT
AT THE STATE'S ON WILDFIRE
RESPONSE CAPACITY AND
ESTABLISHES GOALS AND IDENTIFY
GAPS AND WEAKNESSES AS PART OF
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET AND BACKGROUND ASSESSMENT. WAS NEVER COMPLETED. SO IN OF
THE I'M RECOMMENDED WOULD A
ORDER TO ENSURE THE STATE IS
PREPARED TO ADDRESS. ONGOING
INCREASES IN NUMBER. IN AN
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE MANNER
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DEVELOP A
STRATEGIC PLAN FOR ENHANCING ITS
EMERGENCY RESPONSE CAPACITIES.
AND SUBMIT THIS PLAN TO THE
LEGISLATURE BY JANUARY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. OUR WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE PLAN INCLUDES
FOUR COMPONENTS AND ASSESSMENT
AT THE EXISTING CAPACITY. I CAN
I THINK HE SHOULD HAVE SPECIFIC
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES FOR
EMERGENCY. RESPONSE CAPACITY AND
CAPABILITIES. I WEAKNESS AND
GAPS THE STATE'S CURRENT ABILITY
TO MEET THOSE GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES. AND STAFFING NEEDS
FOR ONLY ASK ANAHIT STRATEGY FOR
OUTLINING STAFFING- THAT'S
CORRECT THE STAFFING PLAN
COMPONENT. SUCH A STRATEGIC PLAN
WOULD ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE
DETERMINED THE EXTENT TO WHICH
EXISTING LBS CAPACITY IS
INSUFFICIENT AND WHETHER THE
ADMINISTRATION SCHOOLS AND A
CRAZY AND PRIORITIES ALIGN WITH
THE LEGISLATURE SYMBOLS I'M
PRIORITIES. AND I AM GONNA TURN
OFF MY VIDEO SAME HERE YOU GUYS
ARE HAVING SOME. DIFFICULTY
HEARING. HOPEFULLY YOU CAN HEAR
ME NOW AND- SO JUST TO CONTINUE
IDEALLY L. YES WOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DEVELOP A STRATEGIC
PLAN THAT WE RECOMMEND
ESTABLISHING EMERGENCY
RESPONSABLES AND ASSESSING
CURRENT CAPABILITIES AS WE
RECOMMEND IN THE PLAN OUR
INTERNAL TO THE PERMISSION OF L.
YES HOWEVER- YES HAS BEEN UNABLE
TO CONDUCT THE SIMILAR AND MORE
NARROWLY SCOPED ASSESSMENT OF
WILDFIRE RESPONSE CAPACITY. THAT
WAS REQUIRED AS PART OF THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET
PACKAGE. GIVEN THIS WE RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE PASCAL YES
I DURING THESE BUDGET HEARINGS
WHETHER IT'S ABLE TO DEVELOP A
STRATEGIC PLAN FOR ENHANCING
EMERGENCY RESPONSE CAPACITY
BEFORE TASKING L. YES WITH
DURING CELL IF THE LEGISLATURE
TAKES OUR RECOMMENDATION. THIS
WOULD ALSO PROVIDE- YES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INDICATE WHAT
RESOURCES IT MIGHT NEED TO
DEVELOP A STRATEGIC PLAN THAT WE
RECOMMEND. TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
**** UNABLE TO COMMIT TO%
DEVELOPING A PLAN THE
LEGISLATURE COULD ASK- YES TO
RECOMMEND ALTERNATIVE ENTITIES
THAT WOULD BE BETTER SUITED TO
DEVELOP A PLAN. IN TERMS OF OUR
OVER ARCHING RECOMMENDATIONS WE
ALSO RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE THAT THE
HELL YES BASED BUDGET BE
REPEALED AFTER THE COMPLETION OF
THE STRATEGIC PLAN THAT WE
RECOMMEND. SUCH A REVIEW WOULD
DETERMINE THE EXTENT TO WHICH
EXISTING RESOURCES ARE MEETING
THE GOALS IN THE STRATEGIC PLAN.
WHETHER SOME RESOURCES SHOULD BE
RE ALLOCATED TO HIGHER PARTY
USES. AND THE EXTENT TO WHICH
RESTOCK MEDICATIONS HAVE ALREADY
PROVIDED THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES. THIS BASED BUDGET
REVIEW COUPLED WITH THE
STRATEGIC PLAN WOULD ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE THE INFORMATION HE
NEEDS TO DETERMINE HOW TO
ALLOCATE FUNDS. TO ENHANCE THE
STATE'S EMERGENCY RESPONSE
CAPACITY IN THE MOST EFFICIENT
AND EFFECTIVE MANNER IN FUTURE
YEARS. NOW IN TERMS OF SPECIFIC
PROPOSALS FROM OTHER PROPOSALS
OUT FOR- YES IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ARE DIFFICULT TO ASSESS
WHAT THE CURRENT LACK OF ITS
STRATEGIC PLANNING FOR HOW TO
ENHANCE THE STATE'S EMERGENCY
RESPONSE CAPACITY. FOR THESE
PROPOSALS WE RECOMMEND PROVIDING
THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM FUNDING.
THIS RECOMMENDATION WOULD APPLY
TO THE SUPPORT CAPACITY AND
LOGISTICS MANAGEMENT PROPOSALS
IN THIS ITEM AS WELL AS OTHER
ITEMS LATER IN THE AGENDA. UNDER
THIS APPROACH THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD PROVIDE THE REQUESTED
FUNDING IN RECOGNITION THAT- YES
MIGHT NEED ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO FURTHER ENHANCE THESTATE'S
EMERGENCY RESPONSE CAPABILITIES.
BUT THIS WOULD ALLOW THESE
AUGMENTATIONS TO BE REVISITED
AND THREE YEARS AFTER THE
STRATEGIC PLAN AND REVIEW THE
DEPARTMENT'S BASE BUDGET HAVE
BEEN COMPLETED. REGARDING THE
MISSION TASKING PROPOSAL IN THIS
ITEM WE HAVE TO CONSIDER. FIRST
THE PROPOSED SPENDING IS
INTENDED TO PROVIDE FUNDING
FLEXIBILITY BUT APPEARS TO HAVE
A SIMILAR STORY INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET THROUGH THE NINETY EIGHT
FORTY EIGHT AM. WHICH ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE UPON
NOTIFICATION TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE%
ARGUMENT THE BUDGET OF THE
DEPARTMENT IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES. WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION INTENDS
TO USE THIS FUNDING TO ADDRESS
WHAT IT BELIEVES IS A GAP IN
EXISTING EMERGENCY SPENDING
AUTHORITIES. INCLUDING PROVIDING
FUNDING IN CASES WHERE THE
FUNDING UNDER THE NINETY EIGHT
FORTY EIGHT AM THAT WE VIEW AS
AN ALTERNATIVE MIGHT NOT BE
AVAILABLE. WELL IT'S POSSIBLE
THERE COULD BE CIRCUMSTANCES
WHEN THE NINETY EIGHT FORTY ITEM
OR OTHER EXISTING FUNDING
SOURCES ARE NOT A GOOD FIT. THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT BEEN ABLE
TO IDENTIFY THE EXTENT TO WHICH
THIS PROBLEM EXISTS OR THE SIZE
OF THE GAP IN OTHER EMERGENCY
FUNDING AUTHORITIES THAT THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD ADDRESS. SECOND
THE PROPOSED FUNDING CIRCUMVENT
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT BY NOT
REQUIRING NOTIFICATION AT THE
USE OF FUNDS. I WOULD ONLY
REQUIRE A ONE TIME REPORT IN
MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
ACCORDINGLY WE RECOMMEND
REJECTING THIS PROPOSAL. AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
I'M SURE WOULD YOU- LIKE GAP
FROM THE FINANCE TO- THE
COMMENTS BEFORE QUESTIONS ARE
DIRECTED ENTERTAIN QUESTIONS
FIRST. DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO
ADD. I JUST A FEW THINGS I WAS
JUST GOING TO ADD THAT WHILE WE
RECOGNIZE THE GROWTH IN- YES IS
BUDGET BUT DIFFICULT OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS AND WHILE
MANY OF THOSE AUGMENTATIONS
APPEAR TO BE KIND OF DUPLICATIVE
IN NATURE GIVEN THE TYPES OF
CLASSIFICATIONS THAT WERE ADDED-
THE ONES THAT HAVE BEEN
AUTHORIZED TO. INTERPRET PRIOR
YEARS HAVE GENERALLY BEEN VERY
TARGETED IN TERMS OF THE TYPES
OF- DIRECTORATES ARE AREAS
WITHIN ONLY ADDS. BETTER BEING
ENHANCED. SO FOR EXAMPLE LAST
YEAR THERE ARE A LOT OF
RESOURCES THAT ARE PUT IN PLACE
FOR LOGISTICS OR OTHER TYPES OF
DIRECTORATE WE TALKING ABOUT
HERE. BUT THAT WAS REALLY
TARGETED AT READING A STUDY
STATE STREET OPERATIONS CENTER
BASED STAFFING- BECAUSE-
PREVIOUSLY THE STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER ALWAYS REDIRECTED FROM.
HE ADDED DIRECTORATES TO SUPPORT
ITSELF AND GIVEN THE ONGOING.
AND FREQUENT USE OF THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER. IS A
RECOGNIZED NEED TO CREATE MORE
BAY STAFFING THERE SO WELL THOSE
APPEAR TO BE SIMILAR. RESOURCES
BECAUSE OF THE TYPES OF
CLASSIFICATIONS THAT THEY
ADDRESSED. THE FOCUS AND PURPOSE
IS VERY DIFFERENT THAN.
ENHANCING JUST THE BASED STUDY
STATE OF THE DEPARTMENT-
SECONDLY JUST WANT TALK BRIEFLY
ABOUT THE- MISSION TASKING
PREPARATION. OBVERSES NINETY
EIGHT HUNDRED. WE BELIEVE THAT
THE FRAME NINETEEN HUNDRED IS
MUCH BROADER THAN. REGENCY
RESPONSE AND THAT IT IS CRAFTED
IN A WAY THAT IS- SET UP TO
MAINTAIN SOME. OF A PORTENT
GUARDRAILS FOR UNANTICIPATED
COSTS OUTSIDE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
AND THAT TRYING TO ADAPT THAT
MECHANISM TO. BE NIMBLE THAT
WITH THE LEVEL THAT WORKS
RESPONSE REQUIRES. WOULD
COMPROMISE SOME OF THOSE- GUARD
RAILS OR OTHER NON EMERGENCY
RESPONSE RELATED UNANTICIPATED
COSTS- WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
IS A- PRIMARY CONCERN BEING
RAISED IS TRANSPARENCY. AND
SHARING OF INFORMATION THE
LEGISLATURE AND WE'RE OPEN TO.
ADDING BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO
OUR REQUEST THAT WOULD REQUIRE.
NOTIFICATION WITHIN TEN DAYS- OF
ANY APPROVALS BEING MADE TO THE-
WEBSITE BUDGET COMMITTEE AND THE
AND THE CHAIRS OF THE- BUDGET
COMMITTEES ARE SIMILAR TO OTHER.
EMERGENCY RESPONSE.
AUTHORIZATIONS THAT EXIST NOW-
TO HELP WITH THAT TRADE. AND
OVERSIGHT ROLE SO WITH THAT-
HAPPY TO HELP ANSWER ANY
QUESTION. THANK YOU- I WOULD
START WITH THE QUESTION FOR- OH
YES- I HAVE SEEN JUST EVEN WHILE
PRICES FOR IT THERE WERE. OUR
FIRE SEASON SEEMS TO BE AROUND
HIM ANYMORE EMERGENCY IS AND SO
I DO UNDERSTAND- IMPART WIFE THE
BUDGET HAS GROWN EXPONENTIALLY-
WITH WITH THE VARIOUS
EMERGENCIES THAT WE ARE
CONFRONTED WITH- AND THAT'S JUST
THE LAST TWO YEARS ALONE. BUT
GIVEN THE REALITY GIVEN THAT WE
ARE OFTEN BEING HEARD SAYING
THINGS LIKE OUR FIRE SEASON IS
YEAR ROUND NOW- YOU KNOW KIM
KENDALL YES RESPONSE TO THE
ALLEY ELLIS RECOMMENDATION FOR
AN OVER. ARCHING STRATEGIC
PLANNING- YOU KNOW SO THAT WE
CAN ENSURE THAT WE COULD DO OUR
JOB A LITTLE BIT BETTER AS WE
TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO THE
OVERSIGHT. IT'S DIFFICULT WHEN
WE HAVE ALL THIS GROWTH.
EXPENDITURE THIS DIRECTOR
GUARDED SHE- DO APPRECIATE THE
L. A. O. EGG EGG KNOWLEDGE IN
FIRST FALL THAT THE CHALLENGES I
DO APPRECIATE YOUR KNOWLEDGE IN
THE CHALLENGES- WILDFIRE SEASON
IS YEAR ROUND BUT I THINK IT'S
NOT JUST THE FACT THAT IT'S
WHILE PARTICIPATING YEAR ROUND.
IT'S THAT IT'S THAT THE SCOPE
AND SCALE COMPLEXITY OF THE
DISASTERS THAT WE'RE SEEING UP
AND HOW MUCH THEY'RE IMPACTING
THE COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ARE THE REQUIREMENTS TO
RESPOND ARE MUCH FASTER MUCH
MORE IN IN INCOME- INTENSIVE-
AND- YOU KNOW OP WE'VE TOLD LA-
THAT WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO SIT
WITH THEM TO HELP TO- SHE CHECK-
WHY AM I JUST WILL TELL YOU- WE
WERE UNDER RESOURCE GOING INTO
THIS THE LAST FEW YEARS HAVE
BEEN UNPRECEDENTED WE DON'T SEE
ANY IF IT'S SLOWING DOWN. IT'S
BEEN A LOT OF OUR TIME- BUILDING
PLANS- BUT WE HAVE TO BE
RESPONDING TO THESE EVENTS- THE
L. A- MENTIONED NOT GETTING A
PARTICULAR- REPORT- IT WITH THAT
YOU KOW I WAS IN CALIFORNIA OF
COURSE WERE PRETTY BUSY AND
DIDN'T DIDN'T GET TO WHERE- SO
THE REALITY IS THAT- WE WILL
WORK WITH THE L. A. HOPE TO BE
ABLE TO. DO UP WITH THE GAP OR
SOMETHING THAT WOULD HELP YOU-
PROVIDE WHATEVER OVERSIGHT YOU
YOU WOULD YOU THINK YOU NEED FOR
US THAT WOULD BE A PARTNERSHIP
WE WOULD LIKE WITH YOU ABOUT
ALSO PLEASE IF YOU WOULD JUST IT
DOES MEET THIS ONE UP POINT AND
THAT IS THAT IS YOU KNOW. IN
THIS I MEAN JUST. IN GENERAL. OF
THE HIGHER PEOPLE AND TIMELY. TO
IN. YOU KNOW JUST DIDN'T. ACROSS
THE LAND IS CHAO- THIS THIS
PARTICULAR INDUSTRY. ARE YOU
ABLE TO GET. OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
ARE WILLING TO COMMIT THAT KIND
OF. TWENTY FOUR SEVEN THREE
SIXTY FIVE- REQUIREMENTS-
COMMITTEE FAMILY COMMIT THEIR
TIME I MET UP THE EXTENT CATCH
UP IN THIS THAT'S REQUIRED. THE
PEOPLE ARE OUT THERE- BUT- WHEN
WE LIMIT THEM WE SAY THAT LET'S
SAY THIS IS A THREE YEAR-
THERE'S NO. GUARANTEE AND WHAT
ABOUT THE LONG TERM RIGHT TO BE-
BETTER BETTER. CHALLENGE OF
GETTING PEOPLE TO SIGN ON WITH
US- IT IS EXTREMELY DIFFICULT-
SO- I GUESS THE SHORT ANSWER IS
WE WERE HAPPY TO WORK WITH ELIO
AND WITH YOU ON THE PLAN- BUT
ALSO- I JUST SORT OF APPEAL TO
THE- TO YOU THAT THAT THE
UNDERSTAND THAT- YOU KNOW. AS
THEY GET WHERE WE NEED TO GET TO
A WERE ALREADY UNDER. THE CURVE
AND OF THESE DISASTERS ARE NOT
SLOWING DOWN AND- WE KNOW THAT
YOU KNOW. YOU ALL AND LARA LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHERE THE FIRST
PLACE THAT. THE PHONE RINGS WHEN
THERE'S EVENTS THAT NEED TO
HAPPEN AND RESPONSE THAT NEEDS
TO TAKE PLACE. AND WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO SERVE YOU
AND SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES AT.
THE BEST OF OUR ABILITY. SO
THINK WE HAVE A LOT OF COMMON
GROUND WE- THE SISTERS
DEFINITELY NOT DOWN AND MUCH
MARK- AND INTO- IN ANY VENUE DID
TO BILLS HAVE FUNDING GUARANTEE
FOR MORE THAN THREE YEARS SO
THAT YOU CAN MAINTAIN AND-
RETAIN STAFF I THINK THOSE ARE
ALL THINGS THAT WE CAN
UNDERSTAND. BEING ABLE TO HAVE A
- LONG TERM ALL RIGHT SHE'S
REACHES A PLAN ALLOWS OVERSEE TO
BE EASIER WHICH GIVES US MORE
CONFIDENCE IN THESE DOLLARS THAT
WE'RE PUTTING FORWARD I DON'T
THINK. ARE CONCERNED ESTIMATE AT
THIS POINT- THAT YOU NEED TO
CONVINCE US THAT WE NEED MORE
FUNDING FOR LIVING THE STAFF
THERE'S OUR PHONES ARE BLOWING
UP ON A REGULAR BASIS- MORE MORE
OFTEN AND SO WE UNDERSTAND THE
NEED FOR. INCREASED FUNDING AND
SO FORTH WE JUST WANT TO HAVE
THE CONFIDENCE WHEN OUR
TAXPAYERS ARE VOTERS ASK
QUESTIONS THAT THEY ARE CLEAR
IT'S CLEAR TO THEM THAT WE ARE
PUTTING IN THE PROPER OVERSIGHT
AND WE COULD. WITH PRIDESAY
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE DOING AND
IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S ME THE JOB
THAT WE NEED MEN SO I THINK THAT
THOSE PLANS ALLOW US TO HAVE. A
BETTER RELATIONSHIP- S. AS THE
SITUATION CONTINUES TO CHANGE
FOR LOTTERY SITTING INCLUDING
CLIMATE CHANGE OUT THERE. AND SO
I DO APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT
TO WORK WITH THE ALEJO TO TRY TO
COME UP WITH SOMETHING THAT I
THINK. JUST MAKES IT EASIER TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS- OUT THERE I'VE
BEEN TO SOME IS OPERATIONS THEY
ARE INTENSE THERE ARE FAST
MOVING- AND- YOU AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE EFFORT OF THE
TEAMS OUT THERE- AND THEN WE'RE
SEEING THAT MORE AND MORE. UP
OUT THERE THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
AND SO I DO APPRECIATE THAT BUT
WE JUST WANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THE CONFIDENCE WHEN WE TALKED
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE ARE DOING
OUR JOB OF OVERSIGHT AND THAT'S
WHAT THESE PLANS ALLOW US TO DO
. WE WILL WORK WITH YOUR THAT
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE FROM.
OKAY I HAVE A QUESTION AS I HAVE
YOU HERE AND I APOLOGIZE I'M
GOING TO GO OFF THE EDGE AND
THAT'S JUST A LITTLE BIT AT THE
TOPIC THAT I BROUGHT UP I THINK
IN THE LAST THREE OF THE
PREVIOUS HEARING BUT- UNDER.
UNDER R. O. O. E. S. WE HAVE
VICTIM SERVICES AS WELL AND WE
HAD PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED THE
CONSULTATION OF THIS INTO A NEW
AN ENTITY AND I KNOW WE'VE BEEN
DEALING WITH A LOT OF DIFFERENT
EMERGENCIES AND WE'RE TALKING TO
THE ABOUT HOW YOUR DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE GROWING
EXPONENTIALLY OUT THERE THAT
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
DOESN'T GET LOST IN THE PROCESS
OF BOTH EQUALLY IMPORTANT OUT
THERE ARE WE GETTING ANY CLOSER
TO HAVING- YES A MINUTE
TRANSITION PLAN ON. ON THIS
ISSUE ON ON CONSOLIDATING OF
VICTIM SERVICES AND GRANTS INTO
A NEW ENTITY. OF ROGER I THINK
THAT THE- I DO YOU SPEAKING
ABOUT CONSOLIDATING WITH- THE
VICTIMS. VICTIMS PROPOSITIONS
TRANSPORTATION BOARD THAT'S PART
OF IT YEAH BUT THAT'S THAT'S
PART OF THE BIGGER THINGS I
THINK IT WAS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. IN IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THERE WAS A COMMITMENT
TO CONSOLIDATE VARIOUS PIECES
TOGETHER FOR SERVICES. OUT THERE
AND I'M JUST WORRIED THAT US
WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH ALL
THESE EMERGENCIES THAT THIS IS
GETTING LOST AND SO IT'S OKAY
YOU DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER FOR ME
TO DAVID JUST WANTED TO
EMPHASIZE THAT I HOPE WE CAN
FIGURE OUT- HOW YOU. DEAL WITH
THE INTENSE EMERGENCIES AND MORE
OFTEN THAT YOU'RE DEALING WITH
BUT THAT WE DON'T LOSE TRACK OF
A PIECES LIKE OUR VICTIM
SERVICES IN THE CONSOLIDATION
THAT WE HAD. AGREED TO IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND A PLAN
THAT WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOR. YES
THANK YOU FOR THAT- YEAH I WOULD
JUST TELL YOU THAT- IT GIVES
ANOTHER. EXAMPLE OF THAT THAT
UNIQUENESS IS ABOUT WE ASK FOR
WE'VE GOT. YOU KNOW I SORT OF
USE THIS ANALOGY BEFORE IT- YES
IS MUCH LIKE OUT A CITY
GOVERNMENT WE HAVE OUR OWN FIRE
AND RESCUE DEPARTMENT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE'VE GOT OUR OWN. A
PUBLIC WORKS THAT WE HAVE OUR
OWN YOU KNOW GRANTS MANAGEMENT
DIVISION. THROUGHOUT THE- THE
EMERGENCIES AND DISASTERS WE
WORK TO KEEP. OUR BRANCH
MANAGEMENT AND SOME OF THOSE
OTHER OPERATIONAL- ASPECTS IT
TAX SO THAT THEY CONTINUE TO
DELIVER THE SERVICES. MOST OF
THOSE ARE DRIVEN BY METRICS THAT
ARE. ALL REQUIRED TO MEET- AND
CONTINUE TO MEET THOSE DEADLINES
THAT ARE SET FORTH BY. EITHER
STATE OR FEDERAL GRANT
REQUIREMENTS- AS WELL AS WORKING
WITH THE COMMUNITY AT LARGE TO
ENSURE THAT FOR EXAMPLE A
RECIPIENT A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION. THAT IS A
RECIPIENT OF THE GRANT I
CONTINUE TO HOW ABOUT FUNDING
FLOWING- SO THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO DELIVER THE SERVICES
THAT. ARE SO CRITICAL IN THE
FIELD- AND- WE HAVE. WE'RE
EXACTLY- VICTIMS COP. BOARD
WE'VE WE'VE- OF COURSE IT DON'T
NOW WITH A LOOK COME. AND WE
LOOK AT THAT THAT TOTALITY THE
EFFECT INTO TALIBAN CONTINUE TO
WORK AT IT- BUT THE- BUT THERE
THERE'S BEEN YOU KNOW GIVEN THE
COLD IT AND ALL THE OTHER. I'M
OR DID SHE WE KEPT THE
OPERATIONS GOING BUT ON THIS
PARTICULAR TOPIC- YEAH I DON'T I
HAVE TO GO BACK AND CHECK TO SEE
EXACTLY WHERE WE'RE AT BUT-
DON'T HAVE UP. A FINAL ON THAT
TODAY. THAT'S APPRECIATE IT AS
IF WE CANNOT SOMETHING COME BACK
TO US WITH WHERE WE'RE AT WITH
THE CONSOLIDATION PLAN- AND HOW
WE COULD BE OF ASSISTANCE. TO
YOU ON ON THAT ITEM I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT AS YOU CONTINUE
TO GROW YOUR MENDOCINE. OF THE
VARIOUS EMERGENCIES OUT THERE-
THAT WE HAVE SOMETHING THAT DOES
WORK FOR VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS
AND THAT WE ARE DELIVERING ON
PROMISES THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
MADE OUT THERE AND SO. I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION TO
THIS I HAVE A LOT OF CONFIDENCE
IN YOUR ABILITY TO GET THIS DONE
AS YOU MANAGE. VARIOUS EMERGENCY
SHELTER AND SO WILL FOLLOW UP
WITH THAT. BOETTICHER THANK YOU
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER SIX WHICH IS
IMPLEMENTING NINE EIGHT EIGHT
BEHAVIORAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
HELPLINE. YES THEY ARE SO- IN
THIS CASE THE BUDGET PROPOSES
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL
FUND TO IMPLEMENT A NEW
FEDERALLY MANDATED NINE EIGHT
EIGHT SUICIDE HOTLINE CALL
SYSTEM. TO INCREASE THE EASE AND
ACCESSIBILITY TO PROVIDE HELP TO
THOSE CONSIDERING SUICIDE OR
SELF HARM. BORDER NOTE THAT THE
FCC MANDATED THAT
TELECOMMUNICATION CARRIERS TO
IMPLEMENT THIS NEW NINE EIGHT
EIGHT SYSTEM BY JULY SIXTEENTH.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. HELLO YES IS
ROLE AS THE OPERATOR OF THAT
STATE NINE ONE ONE SYSTEM IS
PROVIDING THE TECHNICAL SUPPORT
CAPABILITY AND EXPERTISE TO
STAND UP THE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
THESE NINE EIGHT EIGHT CALLS.
BOB THOSE WHO DIAL IN THE NINETY
EIGHT WILL BE DIRECTED TO ONE OF
THE EXISTING THIRTEEN LIFELINE
CALL CENTERS ACROSS THE STATE.
THE CENTERS ALREADY PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE ASSISTANCE WITH MENTAL
DISTRESS UP WITH THOSE MENTAL
DISTRESS AND THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING WILL ENSURE WITH THE
APPROPRIATE TECHNICAL
ENHANCEMENTS TO BE MADE- THAT
ARE REQUIRED AND ENSURE THAT
THOSE NEEDING SERVICES RECEIVED.
HELP MORE EFFICIENTLY THIS IS
REALLY MAKING SURE THAT THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN US PEOPLE
CALLING NINE ONE ONE CONNECT
OPENED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
MY SERVER SO- IT'S LIKE IT'S UP
YEAH IT'S REALLY THE ORTEZ
FUNDING IS REALLY FOR- THE- WE
ESTEEM TO ENSURE THAT THAT
TECHNOLOGY IN THE CONNECTIVITY.
IS THAT EFFICIENT MANNER. MADAM
CHAIR AT JESSICA PETERS AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
I'VE I'VE HEARD FROM THE HEARING
ROOM THAT MY VIDEOS NOT COMING
THROUGH SO FORGIVE THE- LACK OF
A VISUAL PRESENCE HERE- I FIND
THIS PARTICULAR ITEM- NEED WE
DON'T HAVE AN ISSUE WITH THE
PROPOSAL AND THE PROPOSED AND-
ACTIVITIES THAT- YES WE DO-
WITHIN NINE EIGHT EIGHT. THE
STAND OUTS WITH MENTIONED THIS
IS THE FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS- AND
WHILE- YESS MOST OF THE WAY
TOWARDS MEETING THAT REQUIREMENT
AND- PROVIDING THIS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING WOULD ALLOW FOR THE
INTEGRATION BETWEEN THE NINETY
AND NINE ONE ONE SYSTEMS. AS
WELL AS TEXT CAPABILITY AND
OTHER THINGS THAT I'M SEEM QUITE
REASONABLE AND YOU KNOW HOW
EVERYTHING IS THAT THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN ACT- PROVIDED
FEDERAL FUNDING TO MEET FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS. AND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT YET
REPORTED ON THE EXTENT TO WHICH-
FEDERAL FUNDS HAVE BEEN RECEIVED
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THERE MIGHT
BE SOME FEDERAL FUNDING THAT HAS
COME THROUGH. BUT IT'S UNCLEAR
TO WHAT EXTENT- THOSE DOLLARS
ARE INCLUDED OR ACCOUNTED FOR IN
THIS PROPOSAL AS THIS IS GENERAL
FUND AND NOT FEDERAL FUNDS. AND
HOW THOSE FRIENDS HOW MUCH THE
STATE RECEIVED AND HOW THOSE
FUNDS HAVE BEEN ALLOCATED AND
WHETHER ANY OF IT COULD OFFSET.
ON THE PROPOSED GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS HERE. MEETING AT FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. SYMCOR. VENTURA
FINANCED NOTHING MORE TO ADD BY
WAY OF PRESENTATION BUT HAPPY TO
HELP ANSWER QUESTIONS. TELL US
THANK YOU TO THE O. E. S. IN A-
I APPRECIATE YOUR ROLE RIGHT NOW
AND FACILITATING THEIR FEE
STRUCTURE OF THE THIS HOTLINE.
WHAT ONCE IT'S COMPLETED IS
THERE A ROLE FOR- YES STILL
THERE MOVING FORWARD OR- IS THIS
THIS IS JUST. A ONE AND DONE
TYPE EFFECT IDEAL FOR THIS FOR
THE- S. PACIFIC TO THE NINE
EIGHT EIGHT NINE. YES
MEASUREMENT I HAVE OF MY DEPUTY
DIRECTOR MITCH MEDIC WHICH
OVERSEES THE NIGHT WENT SYSTEM
KINDA ANSWERED THANK THE
SPECIFICS ON THAT **** YEAH
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- YES THERE
IS GOING TO BE AN ONGOING
MISSION THAT WOULD TAKE PLACE
THERE- OBVIOUSLY WITH THE
THIRTEEN SITES IN A MONTH.
TECHNOLOGIES IN PLACE AND
WORKING WITH THE CARRIER'S- AS
THE DOCTOR SHE SAID ENSURING
THAT STANDARDIZATION OF
EQUIPMENT- BUILD OUT TRAINING.
BOB IT'S SUPPORTING THOSE LOCAL.
THIRTEEN LOCAL SITES ALONG WITH
THE INTEGRATION TO THE- EXISTING
FOREIGN FORTY PUBLIC SAFETY
ANSWERING POINTS AT THE SHERATON
POLICE AND- FIRE DEPARTMENTS-
RUN UP AND DOWN THE STATE SO.
THAT WILL CONTINUE- AND THERE IS
AN ONGOING- BUDGETARY REQUEST-
THIS FOR TWENTY THREE POINT FOUR
FOUR A FIVE POINT SEVEN. OR FIVE
POINT EIGHT MILLION. AND SO IT.
IT JUST IT DO YOU EXPECT THAT TO
BE THEN- A CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION IN THE FUTURE I
KNOW THAT IT'S JUST. YOU KNOW-
LIMITED IN CURRENTLY BUT THE
EXPECT THAT TO BE TURNED INTO A
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION. BUT WE
EXPECT THE CONTINUATION THAT THE
FUND- PERSONNEL THE TEN
PERSONNEL- FOR THAT INTEGRATION
OVERSIGHT- AS AS IT ACCORDINGLY
THERE. AND THEN THEY'LL BE LIFE
CYCLE REPLACEMENT COST FOR
EQUIPMENT- SIMILAR TO ALL
TECHNOLOGY PROJECTS WHERE. I'M
EVERY SO MANY YEARS- OF
EVERYTHING HAS TO BE UPDATED. K.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES MR STONE
AND MR LIKE IN NEXT. SO IT'S A
PRETTY IT THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
IN NINE EIGHT SYSTEM. THE
PROBLEM THAT I HAVE IS I'M STILL
TRYING TO FIGURE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S TEN POINT
WHAT'S THE PLAN FOR A RESPONSE.
SO SOMEBODY CALLS NINE EIGHT
EIGHT. THEN WHAT N. AND IF
THEY'RE GONNA CALL AND THERE'S
NOT A PLACE. FOR THAT CALL TO BE
REFERRED CONSISTENTLY ACROSS THE
COUNTIES AND THERE'S NOT AN
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE. NOBODY'S
GONNA CALL MY EIGHTY IN IN. FOR
VERY QUICKLY GOING TO LEARN THAT
THAT'S NOT. A PATH THAT WILL BE
PRODUCTIVE THAN THOSE QUICKLY
CALL NINE ONE ONE THE POINT IS
TO TAKE. IS TO HAVE AN
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE RATHER JUST
LAW ENFORCEMENT THIS IS A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS BUT ALSO TAKE SOME
OF THE BURDEN OFF LAW
ENFORCEMENT. SO IF WE SET UP
THIS NICE SYSTEM BUT IT'S NOT
CONNECTING ANYONE ANYWHERE. THEN
WHAT. I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLARIFY- MITCH
MEDIC IS A CHICKEN THE SO NINE
EIGHT EIGHT WILL BE IMPLEMENTED
SOMEWHERE NINE ONE ONE BY THE
CARRIERS IN JULY. AND WE HAVE
THIRTEEN EXISTING SITES THAT ARE
LOCALLY RUN OF THOSE CALLS WILL
THEN AUTOMATICALLY ROUTE TO
THOSE SITES. WHERE YOU GET INTO
THE CHALLENGES AND AS AS IT IS
EXPRESSED BEFORE IS THAT. IF A
CALL IS GOING TO A NINE ONE ONE
CENTER THE NEEDS TO GO TO A NINE
EIGHT EIGHT OR VICE VERSA AS THE
SITUATION CHANGES- YOU DON'T
WANT TO HAVE A LOSS OF
INFORMATION OR PUT PEOPLE IN THE
BACK OF THE QUEUE EITHER
WAITING. OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT
AND YOU WANT THE EQUIPMENT
STANDARDIZED AMONG THE THIRTEEN
SITES AND YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE CALL IS ROUTED.
APPROPRIATELY AND GETS TO THE
COST CENTER AND IT'S GOING BACK
AND FORTH BETWEEN THE NINE ONE
SITES- THAT'LL TAKE PLACE SO THE
CALL WILL BE ANSWERED- NOW BUT
IT'S JUST WHEN YOU START THESE
COMPLEXITIES AND THE CHALLENGES
OF EMERGING MANAGEMENT WORKING
WITH. THE VARIOUS- ENTITIES YOU
CAN YOU CAN NOT WITHOUT A GOOD
STANDARDIZED PROGRAM. THAT IS IN
PLACE AND FUNDED AND SUPPORTED
YOU CAN HAVE THE ABSENT THAT'LL
EXIST AND WE JUST WANT TO RISK
ANY. OF PUBLIC SAFETY-
HEALTHCARE AND OF COURSE
OBVIOUSLY ALL OF THIS HAS TO BE
WORKING COORDINATION WITH CHS-
BECAUSE- WE ARE NOT- TAKING A
ROLE IN THE BEHAVIORAL
SPECIALIST SIDE- BUT WE ARE-
SUITED AND CAPABLE. OF ASSISTING
IN THIS TECHNOLOGICAL- ENDEAVOR
TO ENSURE THAT STANDARDIZATION
AND IMPLEMENTATION WORKS
PROPERLY RIGHT BUT ONE OF THE
TOUGHEST CONNECT THAT THAT I
HAVE HERE IS THAT YOU'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR. THE TECHNICAL
SIDE OF THE SYSTEM TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S NOT A FUSION WITH NINE
ONE ONE. THAT THE TWO SYSTEMS
INTERACT. THAT'S FINE BUT- FOR
THE BEST. AND I KNOW IT'S BABY
ANOTHER AGE BUT WE'RE I THINK
WE'RE HEADED FOR POTENTIAL
DISASTER HERE IF CALLS COME IN
AND THEY GET MANAGED JUST FINE
WITH ALL THE TECHNOLOGY. BUT
THERE'S NO APPROPRIATE RESPONSE.
THERE'S NO PLACE FOR THAT CALL
ULTIMATELY BE ROUTED. THEN WE
HAVE A VERY NICE TECHNOLOGICAL
SOLUTION WITH NOTHING WITH
WITHOUT AN APPROPRIATE RESPONSE.
TO THE CRISIS THAT. GENERATE THE
CALL THE FIRST PLACE. YEAH THIS
MARK- BAKER- AS WE UNDERSTAND IT
WHICH I REMEMBER- SO I HELP HIM
TO SERVICES WORKING ON TRAINING
AND PROTOCOLS THAT WERE THAT
WILL BE PUT IN PLACE TO ADDRESS
JUST WHAT YOUR YOUR- YOUR RACING
HERE AND HOW- THE UP THE- CALLS
WILL BE ROUTED WHAT. THE
RESPONSIBILITIES WILL BE WHETHER
IT'S AND I WILL ONCE CENTER OR
AT NIGHT AT CHATTER- THE METRICS
THAT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR IS TO
ENSURE THAT YOU DON'T KNOW CALL
IS LOST- THAT IS ANSWERED IN A
TIMELY WAY- AND THAT THEM AND
THAT THEY ARE. YOU KNOW THEY
DON'T MEET THE REQUIREMENTS- I
DON'T WANNA GO TOO FAR OUT OF MY
LATEST IN BEING ABLE TO TELL YOU
EXACTLY HOW TO DO IT BECAUSE I'M
I'M NOT. UP THERE WHERE BUT I
THINK THAT YOUR POINT- INSURANCE
OF BOB THE TECHNOLOGY AND BE OUT
WHAT HAPPENS AFTER THE
TECHNOLOGY WHEN THE CALL. IS
ROUTED- ALL THAT ALL COMES IN
THE IN THE PLAY IT'S OF GREAT
CONCERN DOUBT- SOMETHING. THAT
YOU KNOW- I HEAR YOU AND WE'LL-
LOOK BACK WITH OUR H. JUST.
BROKE BABIES ELSE WE COULD.
COLLECTIVELY PROVIDE- RICHARD.
MISTER LUCKY. YEAH THANK YOU-
THERE THERE'S JUST SOME
AMBIGUITIES THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IF YOU COULD CLARIFY A
LITTLE BIT FOR ME- FIRST OF ALL
AS THE L. A- INDICATED THERE'S
BEEN SOME SOME FEDERAL FUNDS
HAVE BEEN ALLOCATED CAN YOU TELL
ME ABOUT HOW MUCH AND WHAT WAS
DONE WITH THAT. FUNDING. WHAT WE
DO KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME
FEDERAL GRANT- I FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT UP FINDINGS THAT WERE
PROVIDED TO THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
TO IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM- THOSE
THOSE PLANS HAVE BEEN COMMITTED
BY HHS AT THIS POINT- AND-
DIFFERENT. WAS NO FUNDING THAT
WAS PROVIDED OH YES- TO DO WITH
THAT TECHNOLOGY PIECE OF IT- AND
THAT WAY TO SUPPORT THE PROGRAM-
SO WHERE YOU KNOW. I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHERE AGENTS IS THAT IN
THE IMPLEMENTATION PHASE AT THIS
POINT- AND WE ARE HOPING THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- THE-
THAT THE CURRENT ACTIVE WORKING
ON. WILL AMPLIFY ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT THEY SET FORTH
IN THIS PROGRAM. SO- I MEAN I
DON'T EVEN KNOW I DON'T EVEN
KNOW EXACTLY HOW MUCH FUNDING-
BURKE WAS ACTUALLY GIVEN THE HHS
ON THIS TOPIC. OKAY WELL JULY IS
NEARBY. AND- IT SEEMS. STE THE
STRIKE OF FRESH TO THOSE OF US
WHO ARE OVER. THE THAT THERE
HASN'T BEEN GREAT COORDINATION
BETWEEN HHS AND YOU FOLKS AND
THEY'RE THEY'RE REALLY NEEDS TO
BE A GREAT COORDINATED EFFORT.
IN ORDER FOR THIS TO BE A
SUCCESSFUL UNDERTAKING SO I'M
HOPING THAT- THINGS WILL. HAVE
SOME KIND OF SYNTHESIS HERE
PRETTY. PRETTY SOON OTHERWISE-
WE'RE ALL GONNA HAVE A LOT OF
FRUSTRATION SO I HOPE THAT THIS-
GETS A LITTLE MORE CLEAR. OKAY
SO I JUST WANT TO REITERATE- I
DON'T THINK IT'S OUR EXPECTATION
THAT- YES IS GOING TO HAVE THE
ANSWERS FOR WHAT HAPPENS ONCE
YOU SET UP THE TECHNOLOGY AND
ROUTE THE CALL TO THE CORRECT
LOCATION I THINK OUR CONCERN IS.
TO ENSURE THAT BOTH WHETHER IT'S
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT OR- THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WE HAVE THE
PLANS ARE APPROPRIATE TO THAT.
THE INDIVIDUAL WHO NEED SERVICES
AT SOME PLACE TO GO OTHER WAYS
THAT THE PHONE CALL AND A BRIDGE
TO NOWHERE. AND SO YOU KNOW I
JUST WANT TO BE MINDFUL OF WHOSE
LANE THAT IS- AND- YES COULD DO
EVERYTHING RIGHT SET UP THE
TECHNOLOGY TO MAKE SURE CALLS
pARE BEING ROUTED PROPERLY TO THE
NINE ONE ONE WHEN YOU NEED TO
VERSES NINE EIGHT EIGHT- BUT
WHAT HAPPENS. AFTER THAT AND
IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT BETWEEN NOW
AND JULY WE HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE
PLAN TO ENSURE THAT WE SUCCEED.
OUT THERE INCITING MARC MY
QUESTION IS MORE OR MY COMMENT
IS MORE FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCING FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION- OF- WHAT WE'RE
DOING TO ENSURE THAT THATBRIDGE
GOES SOMEWHERE. FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHEN THEY GET. WHEN
THE TECHNOLOGY WORKS AND THEY
GET ROUTE IT BUT THEY NEED TO BE
ABOUT IT SOME PLACE I NEED TO BE
SOMETHING ON THE BACK AND IT'S
NOT CLEAR THAT WE HAVE THAT YET.
AND THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET
THERE BY JULY. YOU BETTER
FINANCED LIKE IT'S JUST FOR ONE
MOMENT- WE I THINK YOU'RE- FULLY
HEAR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THE HHS
COUNTERPARTS. HAVE GOT THOSE
PLANS IN PLACE WHAT WE HAPPY TO
FOLLOW UP WITH THEM TO MAKE SURE
WE CAN GET SOME INFORMATION. TO
THE COMMITTEE TO HELP OUR-
INCREASE THE CONFIDENCE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLANNING IN
THAT AREA. OKAY WE LIVE FAR FROM
THAT ANTI APPRECIATE MISTER
LUCKY SOME ASSISTANCE COMMON
FUND IN THAT SENSE OF URGENCY.
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN WHICH
IS OUR CALIFORNIA EARLY
EARTHQUAKE WARNING SYSTEM. OKAY
ROGER THANK YOU- IT KNOB THE
PROPOSAL- FULLER ASK FOR
SEVENTEEN POINT ONE MILLION- AND
THREE POSITIONS TO SUPPORT THEIR
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE EARLY
WARNING PROGRAM AS YOU KNOW OUR
MAY KNOW THAT THIS IS THE STATE
OF THE ART SEISMIC WARNING
SYSTEM DESIGNED TO PROVIDE EARLY
WARNING OF AN IMPENDING
EARTHQUAKE- DEPENDING ON WHERE
YOU ARE STANDING. IN RELATION TO
THE EPICENTER OF THE EARTHQUAKE.
GET A FEW SECONDS UP TO NINETY
SECONDS OF WARNING- THAT THE
EARTHQUAKE IS ACTUALLY COMING
YOUR WAY- THE SYSTEM IS A
STATEWIDE SYSTEM AND HAS ALREADY
BEEN- ESSENTIAL IT PROVIDING
EARLY NOTIFICATIONS OP
EARTHQUAKES ON MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS VERY SUCCESSFULLY- THE
APPROVAL OF THIS PARTICULAR.
PROPOSAL WOULD BE EACH YEAR A
FEW THINGS NECESSARY TO CONTINUE
THE OPERATION OF THE SYSTEM.
OFFERS IT WOULD INCREASE THE
SENSOR DENSITY ARE INTO THE-
RURAL PARTS OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA- WE CONTINUE TO BUILD
OUT THIS THE SENSOR ARRAY THE
CENTERS ARE CRITICAL AND BEING
ABLE TO. DETECT THE GROUND
MOTION AND- ECCENTRICITY THAT
THIS WOULD INCREASE THE CENTER
DENSITY SECOND IT WOULD FIND-
GRANTS TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS OUGHT TO PROVIDE
EDUCATION TO THE SOCIALLY
ISOLATED GROUPS. AND OTHER
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES ARE ON
THE PROGRAM HOW TO UTILIZE IT-
NO ABOUT IT TO HELP SAVE LIVES
AND PROTECT PROPERTY
ACCORDINGLY- AND THEN THE THIRD
IS THAT IT WOULD SUPPORT-
CONTINUED NECESSARY RESEARCH. A
PARTICULAR AREA OF NEW PUBLIC
ALERT METHODS SO THAT WE WITH
THAT THE KEY HERE IS SPEED- THE
FASTER WE CAN GET THE SIGNAL
OUT- TO INDIVIDUALS- THE FASTER
THAT THAT- THEY CAN REACT AND-
EVERY REALLY THEY'LL THEY'LL
TERM EVERY SECOND COUNTS
DEFINITELY. OPPORTUNITIES HERE-
AND IT'S NOT JUST FOR
INDIVIDUALS IT'S REALLY FOR ALL
OF OUR INDUSTRIES IT'S HOW FAST
CAN WE SLOW OR STOP A TRAIN THAT
THE- YOU KNOW THAT EARTHQUAKE IS
COMING. OUT SO THAT THE TRADE
DEFICIT HE RAIL YOU KNOW OUR
HELP IN THE MEDICAL INDUSTRY-
YOU KNOW IF THEY'RE DOING SOME
VERY DELICATE SURGERY THEY MAY
TAKE A BREAK- UNTIL THE
EARTHQUAKE PASSES- ECCENTRICITY
THERE'S OF MANY AREAS OF.
SECTORS BENEFITED FROM A
MEDICATION STAMP. AS WELL THE
LIGHTS STEM- BUT BASS TRAP. OP
ASK IS TO CONTINUE TO THE IS
THIS AREA. MADAM CHAIR JUST
COMPUTERS WITHOUT THE CITY OF
ANALYST OFFICE AND THIS PROPOSAL
IS ONE OF THE ONES THAT I NEEDED
TO EARLIER. THAT WE THINK- IT'S
HARD TO A FAST IN THE ABSENCE OF
A STRATEGIC PLANNER FOR HOW THE
STATE ENHANCES ITS EMERGENCY
RESPONSE CAPACITY I'M THE
GOVERNOR HERE IS PROPOSING TO
MAKE PERMANENT- ROUGHLY THE SAME-LEVEL OF FUNDING THAT'S PROVIDED
IN RECENT YEARS ON A ONE TIME
BASIS. TO CONTINUE DEVELOPING
THE SYSTEM- AS THE DIRECTOR
MENTIONED WHILE THE SYSTEM IS
POTENTIALLY PROMISING WITHOUT A
STRATEGIC PLAN IT'S UNCLEAR HOW
THE CURRENT APPROACH TO BUILDING
OUT THE SYSTEM WOULD ALIGN IT
WITH THE STATE'S OVERALL
EMERGENCY RESPONSE SCHOOLS WHICH
AS WE NOTED EARLIER HAVEN'T YET
BEEN DEVELOPED. I'M NOT SO
ACCORDINGLY WE WOULD RECOMMEND
IF THE LEGISLATURE APPROVES THIS
PROPOSAL APPROVE IT- WITH THREE
YEAR LIMITED TERM FUNDING SO
THAT IT CAN BE REASSESSED IN
THREE YEARS SO ONCE THE
STRATEGIC PLAN AND REVIEW OF-
YES THIS BE SPENT CHECK. HAVE
BEEN COMPLETED- AND I WOULD JUST
FURTHER NOTE THAT THAT APPROACH
IS CONSISTENT WITH WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS DONE IN THE PAST
TO FIND THAT REALLY WEREN'T
PERFECT EARLY WARNING SYSTEM
WHICH HAS BEEN TO PROVIDE AB ONE
TIME FUNDING- THAT SO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CONTINUE TO REVIEW THE
PROGRESS OF THIS SYSTEM. AS WELL
AS- YESS AFTERWARDS TO DEVELOP
THE SYSTEMIC NOW LOOK FOR OTHER
FUNDING SOURCES BEYOND JUST
STATE FACTS. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THE BILL WITH PART
FINANCE WE THAT THIS PROGRAM IS
AT A POINT WHERE WE DO NEED
ONGOING STABLE FUNDING AND THAT
GIVEN THE GENERAL BENEFIT THIS
IS TO. ALL SECTORS OF THE STATE
THAT- ONGOING GENERAL FUND IS AN
APPROPRIATE. SOURCE IN
SUPPORTING THE SPACE PROGRAM AND
THAT THERE I THINK IS THAT.
DIRECTOR CALLING US- NO THERE IS
A SPACE FOR KIND OF A MINIATURE
ONE TIME TYPE OF FUNDING OR THE-
VARIOUS SECTORS CAN STILL
PARTICIPATE IN HELPING TO
SUPPORT THE SYSTEM. SO WITH THAT
I HAVE AVAILABLE TO HELP ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. AT THANK YOU- I
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS ACTUALLY
. ONE IS DISPOSABLE SHUTTLE HAVE
THE SYSTEM ON MY PHONE-
APPROXIMATELY HOW MANY PEOPLE
HAVE THE ALERTS ON- FOR THE
SYSTEM ALREADY. SO MANAGER
DIRECTOR- FIRST I WOULD
ENCOURAGE EVERYONE HERE TO
DOWNLOAD THE MY SHAKE OUT.
PLEASE ARE YOUR PHONE ONLY TAKES
A MINUTE- I THINK WE WILL HAVE
WELL OVER A MILLION SEVEN ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION USERS
CURRENTLY- I'LL CONTINUE TO PUSH
OUT A PUBLIC- EDUCATION ON ON
THIS AND- THIS IS REALLY A FUND
OF UP FOUNDATIONAL AND
FUNDAMENTAL. ROLE OF GOVERNMENT
IN BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE ALERT
AND WARNING- AND- IT IS CREATED
YOU KNOW IS A CRITICAL FUNCTION
OF THIS UP- THE STATE AND
PARTICULARLY CUTTING EDGE
TECHNOLOGY. OUR THAT- HAS BEEN
BUILT OUT WE ARE- YOU KNOW. THAT
YOU'RE A RESPECT ALEJO'S- YOU
KNOW UNDERSTANDING OF THIS BUT-
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS THAT
THIS HAS BEEN A VERY ROBUSTLY.
IMPLEMENTED PROGRAM A WITH MANY
PARTNERS AND ENTITIES WE ARE UP
ROUGHLY 85% BUILT OUT ACROSS THE
STATE IT HAS BEEN- ISSUING
EARTHQUAKE- ALERTS OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
VERY SUCCESSFULLY- AND- AND IT
CONTINUES TO GET BETTER. THIS IS
A SYSTEM OBVIOUSLY OF THE MOST.
ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY THAT
REQUIRES AN ONGOING AND UPDATING
OF THE SYSTEM ON- OVER A REGULAR
ANNUAL BASIS- AND- GIVEN THE
DIVERSITY AND COMPLEXITY OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S DISCOGRAPHY- AND
THE FAULT SYSTEMS THAT EXIST.
ALTHOUGH THE JAPAN AND MEXICO
EARTHQUAKE EARLY WARNING SYSTEMS
THAT THEY'VE HAD THEM FOR YEARS
NOPE LOCATION OF THE WORLD HAS
BEEN S. COMPLEXES CALIFORNIA
WITH REGARDS TO HAVING TO ROLL
OUT THIS AT THIS UC SYSTEM. SO I
WOULD JUST- SAY THAT I UP- YOU
KNOW WHAT. BURKE YOU KNOW THERE
THERE IS A STRATEGIC PLAN ON
THIS WE'VE GOT A BUSINESS PLAN
IT'S BEEN SUBMITTED THE
LEGISLATURE- WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE
UP WE'VE THE LEGISLATURE EVERY
YEAR ON THIS PROGRAM CONTINUES.
TO CREATE THE OF THE LEGISLATURE
ON THIS PRO GRAHAM- AT THE I
JUST TO DIFFER DOWN. THAT THAT
THE THAT THAT MOVIE FOR A WITH
THIS. VERY CRITICAL- I'LL OR
SYSTEM- ISN'T BASED ON ANY-
STRATEGIC A SET OF OBJECTIVES.
IT SET UP- VIæT BOB BODY THAT IS
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR AND
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE IT IS
HELPLESS HI THIS PROGRAM
FORWARD- AND REALLY OUT WE ARE
NOW LEADING THE WORLD. IN THIS
AREA EARTHQUAKE EARLY WARNING
SO- THAT'S. YOU KNOW KIND OF
WHERE WE'RE AT WITH THE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU IN AND TO SEE I MEAN
AT. I WANNA WITH ALL OF YOU TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE HAVE MORE
PEOPLE DOWNLOAD THAT APP SO THAT
OUR INVESTMENT IS GETTING THEIR
MONEY'S WORTH- OUT THERE MY
SECOND QUESTION. IS BACK TO THE
ALLEY WAS COMMENTS ABOUT
PROCURING ADDITIONAL WAYS TO
FUND THIS PROGRAM SO FAR IT'S
ALL BEEN. GENERAL FUND- ARE
THERE SPECIFIC INDUSTRIES THAT
WOULD BENEFIT THE MOST FROM THE
X. TECHNOLOGY AND ARE WE-
IDENTIFYING THEM AND TARGETING
THEM. WORKING WITH US THAT THEY
HELP PAY FOR PART OF THIS THIS
PROGRAM. THE STRETCHERS YES WE
ARE- YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY AREAS OF
FOG WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY
EXTENSIVELY FROM DAY ONE IN FACT
THAT THERE'S REPRESENTATION ON
THE ADVISORY. BOARD MEMBERS-
THAT HAVE BEEN APPOINTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE REPRESENTING THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY FOR
EXAMPLE TRANSPORTATION. OP I
UTILITIES- WORKS HELP MEDICAL
RESERVE AREAS YOU HAVE SECTORS-
AND OF COURSE EDUCATION SECTOR
RIGHT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
KIDS- CAN DROP COVER AND HOLD
WHEN- WHEN EARTHQUAKES COMING SO
THEY CAN GET OUT OF THE GAS.
METER AREAS WE'VE REALLY BEEN
FOCUSING ON- YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
THE INVESTMENTS MADE BY THE
PRIVATE SECTOR BOB FOR EXAMPLE
LET'S TAKE TRANSPORTATION YOU
KNOW PART- ALLEY MTA- CALTRAIN
HAVE ALL BEEN WORKING THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY. VESTED IN
SENSORS ON THEIR TRACKS THEY'VE
INVESTED IN THE ABILITY TO PUT
OUR ALGORITHMS- THE PART ONCE
THEY GET THE WITH A WARNING TO
SLOW OR STOP TRAINS. BOB THEY
HAVE DONE PUBLIC EDUCATION
CAMPAIGNS- THEY'VE INSURED ALL
OF THEIR FOLKS HAVE DOWNLOADED
THE APPS WE WORK WITH- APPLE
AND- GOOGLE ARE TO BE ABLE TO
ENSURE THAT IN THE CASE OF
GOOGLE ANDROID PHONES. THE
PHONES ARE NOW BEING PROVIDED
WHEN YOU BUY A PHONE WITH THE
CAPABILITY OF IMPLEMENTED PHONE
AND WORKING WITH APPLE ABOUT IT
THAT'S A BIG PUT IN. THEIR FAULT
SOTHAT YOU DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE TO DOWNLOAD THE APP WORKING
WITH THEM TO ENSURE THAT THEIR
PHONES ARE. IT ESSENCE OF THE
ACCELEROMETER IN YOUR PHONE HAS
THE ABILITY WERE WE CAN
CROWDSOURCE OF WINTER EARTHQUAKE
IS HAPPENING AND WE CAN MAKE A
DETERMINATION BASED UPON THAT
CROWDSOURCING- ALL AS ANOTHER.
AMPLIFIED- ALL ON OF THE-
GREGORY SAID ON THE- BUT USING
CROWDSOURCING TO AMPLIFY THE
SICK. AND ALERT OF THEIR OR YOU
JUST THE USE OF YOUR PHONE-
BEATRIX OF THE OF IN THE IN THE
MURDER SERVER. BOB EVEN VESTED-
PUTTING THE SENSOR ARRAY SO THE
WHEN B. THEY GET THAT WARNING.
FIRE DOORS THAT THAT WERE THE
FIERY GINGER LOCATED
AUTOMATICALLY COME UP SO THAT IF
THE EARTHQUAKE HAPPENS AND IT.
IMPACTS THE FIREHOUSE THE DOORS
THE PRICKLY HISTORICALLY IN
PREVIOUS EARTHQUAKES I HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO OPEN AND WE CANNOT
GET THE FIRE RAGES OUT THE GO
RESPOND TO THE EARTHQUAKE SO. SO
BEFORE THE EARTHQUAKE EVEN
ARRIVES. THE LIGHTS COME ON THE
UP. THE DOORS ROLL UP AND THE
FIREFIGHTERS OUR ARE ONE STEP
CLOSER IN RESPONDING. TO THE
ATTACK- JUST TO BE GET A HOLD OF
DIRTY THAT THE IN HAS. IN
KEEPING TO INVEST. AS WE WORK
TEM IN THE- OF THE FOR. I WANNA
CONGRATULATE YOUNG THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS AND THE ENTHUSIASM
YOU'RE BRINGING TO THIS. PROJECT
BUT I DO JUST WANT TO GO BACK
TO- WHEN WE PASSED THE INITIAL
BILL. WE MADE A PROMISE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE FIND ADDITIONAL
WAYS TO FUND THIS PROGRAM THE ON
THE GENERAL FUND SO WHETHER
THAT'S FEDERAL. DOLLARS OR- HAVE
IT DOLLARS OUT THERE AND SO I
HOPE WE FIND WAYS TO LEVERAGE
HIS RELATIONSHIP STATUS
HIGHLIGHTED FOR US. TO BRING
THIS ADDITIONAL DOLLARS INTO TO
HONOR THAT PROMISE MADE WHEN WE
PASSED THAT BILL OUT THERE AND
SO I THINK YOU. IDENTIFIED A
NUMBER OF PARTNERSHIPS THAT ARE
MAYBE PRIME TO BE LEVERAGED FOR
SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO COME IN
FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR. FOR
THIS. TO MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ON THIS. YEAH OKAY. WELL THEN-
WITH THAT I WILL GO AHEAD THAT
THAT INTO OUR THAT'S OUR FINAL.
ISSUE FOR TODAY SO I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS. DO WE HAVE ANY FURTHER
COMMENT IN THE ROOM WE DO WALK
ON. YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AT
MANNING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC TELEVISION STATIONS-
DIRECTOR GHILARDUCCI JUST USE
EXAMPLES OF THE- HOW THE
EXISTING CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
TELEVISION EARLIER QUAKE WARNING
SYSTEM WORKS- TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WE DID A PILOT PROJECT-
BUT UNFORTUNATELY IT ONLY COVERS
PART OF THE STATE. WE CAN WARN
PEOPLE USING OUR BROADCASTING
SYSTEM INDEPENDENT OF CELL
TOWERS WERE NOT DEPEND ON CELL
TOWERS WHICH CAN BE OVERWHELMED
. YOU'VE SEEN OUR LARGE
BROADCASTING TOWERS WHICH ARE
NOT SUSCEPTIBLE TO WIND OR
EARTHQUAKE OR ANYTHING THEY
SURVIVE IN AN EMERGENCY AND NOT
THEY CAN BROADCAST AND IT-
THROUGH THE USGS WARNING IN LESS
THAN THREE SECONDS. SO EXACT THE
EXAMPLE OF THE FIRE DOOR
FIREHOUSE OPENING IS CLEARLY
WELL OUR SYSTEM DOES NOT THROUGH
THE DATA CASTING TECHNOLOGY IT
CAN BE USED FOR YOUR LAST
QUESTION PRIVATE SECTOR
INDUSTRIAL FACILITIES LIKE IN
YOUR DISTRICT MANAGER. THEY
COULD GET A QUICK MORNING AND
START TO DAMP DOWN THEIR
PROCESSING EQUIPMENT SO THEY
DON'T HAVE AN UPSET LIKE AT A
REFINERY- THE WITH A MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE
ASKING FOR ONE TIME FUNDING. WE
COULD BUILD OUT THE SYSTEM
FURTHER TO COVER RURAL AREAS AND
AREAS IN THE STATE NOT COVERED
NOW BY THE EXISTING PROGRAM.
THERE WAS A LETTER SENT TO THE
COMMITTEE FROM- THE CHAIR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC TELEVISION
STATIONS ABOUT THIS CAPACITY-
AND- WE HAVE TALKED TO- YES-
WITH- WE ARE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
SEVENTEEN POINT ONE MILLION. SO
WITH ANOTHER MILLION DOLLARS
YOU'D HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DO
THIS THROUGHOUT MOST OF STATE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER PEOPLE IN THE ROOM
OKAY CENA AND I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND MOVE ON TO. PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THE PHONES. THE PHONE NUMBER
TO CONNECT- TO CONNECT ONE
SECOND OF A NUMBER. TO CONNECT-
IS ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
SHOULD ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN OF
YOUR STREAMING THIS HEARING BUT
JUST IN CASE THE NUMBER IS.
877-692-8957 IN THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR FOUR SEVEN. AND THE
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE- OPEN
THE PHONE LINES BIRTH FOR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU HAVE
A PUBLIC COMMENT IF PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE YOU'RE-USING A SPEAKERPHONE PLEASE PICK
UP YOUR HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING
THE NUMBERS. ESPECIALISTA GIVE
YOU YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PUSH IT
BACK IN THE QUEUE ONCE AGAIN
THAT'S ONE THEN ZERO FOUR
COMMENTS. AND WE WILL GO TO OUR
FIRST LINE OF FOURTEEN PLEASE
CONTACT. BY FOURTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SH HELLO CHAIR THE
MEMBER FUNDING BILL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CAMPUS WILL CONTINUE
TO BE THE HEALTH AGENCY I'M
CALLING TO SUPPORT ISSUE NUMBER
SIX UNDER ITEM. SIX NINE ZERO
MAINTAINING AN APPLE VALLEY
BETWEEN NINE ONE ONE NINE EIGHT
EIGHT. TWO HEALTH CRICHTON FINAL
LIKE THIS JULY. IF THE SENSOR TO
PROVIDE VERY STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THE FACT. COULD NOT RESPOND AS
COACH MINISTER TO THAT THE
NINETY. PROPERLY FUNDED BY
PASSING A SMALL ON. THAT OPERATE
A NATIONAL SUICIDE HOTLINE THAT
MISSION AND THANK YOU. Q. WE
WILL NOW GO TO MY NUMBER SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU HEAR
ME. OKAY NINETEEN. EPA-EFE
PROGRAMMING IN STRATEGY IN
PACOIMA. JEFF ORGANIZATION LAST
WEEK FROM GENDER AND START
ATHLETES NINETEEN WORKING ABOUT
CHANGE ONE OF THE NAME YOU'RE
TACKLING THE IMPACT IT BADLY AND
ABOUT THE- I REQUEST DOWN TO THE
TO FORCES OF RACIAL AND GENDER
EQUALITY IF GOVERNMENT FUNDS
BACKED. THAT COMES FROM THE
CRIME BECAUSE SYSTEM. EVEN
ARCHITECTURE THE COMPLETE
ELIMINATION SACRAMENTO LEGAL HE
I'M FINE AND COURT FINES ONE.
WITH THE FEDERAL ATTACK EATING
BILL PRIOR FOR AT THE.
YOU KNOW THAT BLACK CALIFORNIA I
NINETEENTH SENATE HAS MY LIKELY
TO IS IF. TRANSACTION FOR MY
CALIFORNIANS ON RIGHT NOT. A
MORE THAN FIVE TIMES MORE LIKELY
. ABSOLUTELY NO EVIDENCE THAT
CATCHER A CIVIL FEE ONE HUNDRED
B. AND- OF HEALTH PEOPLE KEPT.
WHAT THE HECK. RHETORIC WHAT
EVIDENCE. OF THE WILL CONTINUE
TO MULTIPLE IMPACT BLACK AND
BROWN. CALIFORNIA THE ECONOMIC
SECURITY. ABOUT ALREADY PULLED
FROM ON HOW CAN BANNER I CO.
HAAS BE. HOW BETTER BE HOME IN
FACT WHEN A PARKING RAMP. IN
ORDER TO BUILD ATTACK AFFABLE
AND THRIVING CAL. THANK SO MUCH. LINE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS KEREN
TO CARRY MENTAL HEALTH AMERICA
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE SIX THE MENTAL
THEN- NINE EIGHT LINE MENTAL
HEALTH FUNDING. WHAT THE NEW
NINETY DAY MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
LINE GOING LIFE NATIONWIDE IN
JULY IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT WE
MAINTAIN INTER OPERABILITY
BETWEEN NINE ONE ONE AND NINETY
EIGHT EIGHT I'M NOT WE INSURE
CALL CENTER CAPACITY TO HANDLE
THE INCREASED CALL VOLUME. THESE
INVESTMENTS WILL SAVE LIVES AND
MHC ISN'T STRONG SUPPORT WE ALSO
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO PASS A
SMALL FEE ON PHONE LINES AS
AUTHORIZED BY THE NATIONAL
SUICIDE DESIGNATION I JOIN SURE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S NINE EIGHT
EIGHT SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA IS
FULLY FUNDED. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. HERE WE REPORT A
LINE NUMBER NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KAPANEN AT THE BAR I
THINK IT CALLING ON BEHALF OF
BOTH THE KENNEDY FORUM AND WITH
MEMBER INSTITUTE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT ORGANIZATION PORTRAIT
SHOOT SIX UNDER ITEM ZERO SIX
NINE ZERO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL TO MAINTAIN
CRITICALLY NEEDED IN OPERABILITY
BETWEEN NOW ONE NINETY. EIGHT
CONNECTIONS ARE CRITICAL TO THE
SUCCESS OF ANY NINETY CRISIS BY
GOING LIVE IS JULY WILL ALLOW
CALLS TO BE ROUTED TO THE
APPROPRIATE LOCATION TO EXISTING
LINE A CALL CENTERS FOR PEOPLE
HEALTH EMERGENCIES OR TO DIAL
ONE EIGHT AT. AT THE CO SPONSOR
OF BOTH AB NINETY DAY AND THE
NIGHT IF NOT YOUR REQUEST WE
ALSO HIGHLIGHT THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL ONGOING FUNDING AS
WELL AS COORDINATE BUILT OUT AND
HOW MAY THEY LOOKED AT WITHIN
OUR BROADER HEALTH REFORMS.
INCLUDING PASSING A SMALL BIANCA
MARC IS AUTHORIZED BY THE
NATIONAL SUICIDE. HOTLINE
DESIGNATION ACT THANK YOU. THANK
WE WILL ONLINE I'M TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GOING. COME GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RIAZ ON
ATTORNEY AT THE LAWYERS
COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA-
SPEAKING ON ISSUE NUMBER FOUR I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT BALL A
LEMONADE STAND OF CIVIL
ATTACHMENT. AND GIFT CARDS OF
ALL OUTSTANDING CIVIL IT BACK
AND THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLARS CIVIL AT THAT BUT AS
ASSEMBLY WOMAN CORRECT YES THAT
THIS WILL PROVIDE LITTLE RELIEF
ALLOWING CALIFORNIA BURKE I
COURT THAT. IN A SURVEY WE
CONDUCTED OVER TWO HUNDRED
CALIFORNIANS WITH RECENT TRAFFIC
TICKET 68% BUT THEY CAN'T AFFORD
THEIR TICKET FOR LATE FEES I'M
MORE THAN HAPPY THAT THE PAYING
A COUPLE OF STEPS THAT WOULD
INTERFERE WITH THEIR ABILITY TO
PAY RENT. OR GROCERIES OR
UTILITIES AT BOTH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA AND ASSEMBLY FOUND
THAT THE FEES ARE OUTDATED AND
HAVE DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
BLACK BROWN AND LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. THERE IS NO DATA
OR SCIENCE BACKING UP THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
REDUCE THE FEDERAL ATTACK BY
HALF. THESE ARE FEES THAT GIVE
RISE TO A CONFLICT OF INTEREST
OUR COURT THEY HAVE EXTREMELY
LOW COLLECTION RATES AND THEY
CAUSED AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
PAIN OR THE LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIA BUT NOT FUNDING OUR
COURT BACK THE- LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS BUT FIND A STABLE
BURKE THE FUNDING FOR THE COURT.
PLEASE SUPPORT THE LIMITATION OF
CIVIL ASSESSMENT TO DISCHARGE
ABOLISHED. IT THAT THANK YOUNG.
THANK YOU ONE THIRTY EIGHT GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS TASHA
HENNEMAN AND CALLING BEHALF OF
THE BLACK COUNCIL WHICH IS A
COLLECTION OF LEADERS ACROSS
VARIED SECTORS OF PUBLIC
FEEDBACK IN PRIVATE- ENTITIES
THAT SEEKS TO IMPROVE CONDITIONS
FOR THE BLACK AFRICAN AMERICAN
POPULATION ACROSS CALIFORNIA- WE
DO THAT BY LEADING STRATEGIC
INITIATIVES ACROSS THE STATE-ECONOMIC LEGISLATIVE AND
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT EFFORTS. ON
IT I THINKING PRACTICES AND
IDEAS FOR BLACK PROSPERITY IN
THE REGION AND STATE AND I'M
HERE TO- ALSO AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE LINE AROUND
PRIVILEGED DOCUMENTS REALLY
DISRUPTING PEOPLE'S ABILITY TO
AFFORD BASIC EXPENSES AND SHOULD
BE COMPLETELY ELIMINATED- CIVIL
ASSESSMENTS ARE THE HIDDEN COURT
FEES THAT PENALIZE THE POVERTY-
AS MENTIONED FOR MANY WHO CAN'T
AFFORD. TO PAY THESE ARE JUST
ANOTHER PART THAT THAT THAT-
CREATE INSTABILITY AND ANXIETY-
WE KNOW AS MENTIONED BY AT
EUROPEAN OTHERS THAT BLOCKING
BROWN CALIFORNIANS BEAR THE
BRUNT OF CIVIL ASSESSMENT AND
BECAUSE THE TARGETED POLICING ON
BLACK AND BROWN CALIFORNIANS WHO
MORE LIKELY TO BE PULLED OVER
MORE LIKELY TO BE TICKETED-
WHICH MAY EVEN PROMPT A SIMPLE
ASSESSMENT. BLACK PEOPLE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA MAKE UP JUST
7% OF THE STATE'S POPULATION BUT
OVER 16% OF ALL TRAFFIC STOPS
WHAT CALIFORNIANS ARE OPEN NINE
POINT SEVEN TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
RECEIVE A CITATION FOR AN
INFRACTION THAN WHITE
CALIFORNIANS. THOUGH THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE THAT CHARGING THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN DECENT PEOPLE
BUT- ABILITY TO APPEAR APPEAR IN
COURT AND STRONGLY RECOMMEND AND
THEN- I AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES
THAT THEY SHOULD BE ACTIVE WITH
THAT WE SHOULD BE A COMPLETELY.
ELIMINATED THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. AS A REMINDER IS ONE
THEN FOR A COUPLE COMMENT THAT'S
WHY BAND. WE WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER. THIRTY ONE. YES HELLO
MADAM CHAIRWOMAN MEMBERS MARK
SMITH ON BEHALF OF CAL NINA THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL EMERGENCY NUMBER
ASSOCIATION WHERE THE VOICE OF
NINE ONE ONE DISPATCHERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER SIX
TODAY. IN ALL HONESTY THIS
FUNDING SHOULD HAVE BEEN MADE
AVAILABLE LAST YEAR AS IT STANDS
NOW THE FUNDING FOR CALLOW YES
WILL BE MADE AVAILABLE TO THEM
UNTIL AFTER THIS BUDGET IS
APPROVED IN AFTER. THE NINETY
DAY CALL SYSTEM GOES LIVE
REGARDLESS IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THE TECHNICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. HE CAREFULLY
THOUGHT OUT AND PLANNED IN ORDER
TO FACILITATE THE COMMUNICATION
OF CALLS COMING INTO NINE ONE
ONE AND NINE EIGHT EIGHT AND RE
ROUTING. AND VICE VERSA THE
INFORMATION MUST BE TRIAGED TO
BE ABLE TO BE SENT FROM ONE
SYSTEM TO ANOTHER SEAMLESSLY IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE THE APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF SERVICE. FOR THE
APPROPRIATE CALL AGAIN WE
SUPPORT THIS FUNDING WE DO WE
SHOULD HAVE COME SOONER I DO
WANT TO KNOW IF THERE WAS SOME
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHETHER THE
FEDERAL FUNDING. WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR USE FOR THIS
PARTICULAR PURPOSE WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR FEDERAL
COUNTERPARTS THAT FUNDING IS
PRIMARILY DIRECTED IT END USER
SERVICES SO THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES SIDE OF THE NINETY
EIGHT SYSTEM. IT IS NOT BE MADE
AVAILABLE FOR THE TECHNICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT NEED TO EXIST
AROUND THAT IT'S A WE APPLAUD
THE GOVERNOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOR PROVIDING FUNDING
FOR THAT TECHNICAL CONVERSATIONS
LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YOU KNOW BOTTOM LINE
NUMBER THIRTY THREE WELL I HAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS NICOLE KIANA AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF EVERY TOWN
MEETING IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
IMPLEMENTING- NINE EIGHT AND YOU
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS HOTLINE
IT'S ALSO IMPERATIVE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPT A PERMANENT
INSUFFICIENT FUNDING. FOR FOUR
NINE EIGHT CRISIS LINE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU WE WILL
NOW GO TO THE LINE OF TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. READ WHAT
I'M ABOUT HALF EIGHT THAT YOU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND A MEMBER
OF THE DEBT FREE JUSTICE
COALITION I WANT TO THANK THE
TEN MEMBERS BUT ACCOMPLISH
REGARDING THE LOOK THAT MEANT.
AND IF THE FED THEM I CAN
CURRENT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ALREADY SPOKEN ADVOCATING FOR
THE POOL A LIMITATION THE THREE
HUNDRED DOLLAR CIVIL ASSESSMENT.
THANK YOU HAVE A WONDERFUL DAY.
THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO THE LINE
FIFTEEN IT'S GOING ON. AND IN A
SHOP WITH MARIANA TOURNEY THEY
COMMUNITY LAW CENTER WHICH IS
ONE OF THE LARGEST LEGAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS IN ALAMEDA COUNTY I'D
LIKE TO GET ON ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
AND ALONGSIDE MY COLLEAGUE- YOU
ALSO STRONGLY CONSIDER REDUCING
AND ELIMINATING THE ENTIRE CITY.
AND LATER EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLAR REDUCTION WILL NOT GO FAR
ENOUGH AND TO PLEASE CONSIDER.
DISCHARGING ALL SUPPORT THAT.
THANK YOU Y. NUMBER THIRTY TWO.
I NUMBER THIRTY NINE
RESPECTFULLY POLITICS THANK YOU
MEMBERS REFLECTED ON ON BEHALF
OF COUNTY DISSIPATION
PSYCHIATRIST IN CALIFORNIA
ACADEMYOF JOHN ALLEN THANK HIGH
TREE. SUPPORT ISSUE SIX UNDER
ITEM. THANK REGARDING NINETY
EIGHT THE NEW MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS LINE GOING LIVE IN JULY
WHICH ONLY SUPPORT INVESTING IN
OFF THE EARTH THE LEGISLATURE
AND INSPIRATION TO ENSURE THAT
THE ENTIRE NINE EIGHT EIGHT THE
TENNIS PROPERLY FUNDED BY
PASSING A SMALL FEE. ONLINE
PHONE LINES AS AUTHORIZED BY THE
NATIONAL HOTLINE THAT THE-
DEFINITION ACT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE WILL GO O THE LINE
THIRTY FOUR PEOPLE HAD.
AFTERNOON I'M TRYING NUMBERS
CHRISTOPHER SPONSORS POLICY
ADVOCATE THE WESTERN CINEMA
PROPERTY ACCORDING ALL THE
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES ON
THE SHIP FOR A BIT OF THE CIVIL
SUSSMAN WE WOULD OUR ACT BUT
THOSE ARE FEES WE COMPLETED
TOPIC. THANK YOU LINE NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SEAN YOUNG AND I WORK AT
THE FINANCIAL JUSTICE PROJECT IN
THE OFFICE OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
TREASURER I'M CALLING TODAY WITH
REGARD TO ISSUE FOR INSURGENTS
COMMITTEE TO WORK TOWARD
COMPLETELY ELIMINATING THE
SUPPORT THAT'S BEEN AN
OUTSTANDING CIVIL TOUGH AND
THAT. ARE BACK ON THE COMMENTS
MADE BY THIS PANEL OTHER
COMMENTERS THERE ARE BETTER AND
MORE EFFECTIVE WAYS TO ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO SHOW UP IN COURT BEING
COMPLIANCE THE LAW AND LOBBYING
THAT THEY CANNOT TAKE COURTS ARE
ALREADY USING TOOLS BY TRIAL IN
ABSENTIA AND BANKRUPTCIES TO
PUNISH PEOPLE FOR NON APPEARANCE
WE SHOULD NOT BE PRODUCTIVE
CIVIL ASSESSMENTS. YEAH PREVENT
COURTS FROM USING PUNISHMENT
THAT THEY'RE ALREADY USING- I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE'S
COMMENTS ALSO RECOGNIZED THE
IMPACT THAT THE CIVIL SETTLEMENT
HOW THE LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES WERE
ALREADY OVER PLACE AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE LEGAL SYSTE THE COURT
SHOULD NOT BE TRYING TO FUND
THEMSELVES THROUGH THESE OVERLY
PUNITIVE FEES IT'S AN
INEFFECTIVE COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
WAY. THE FUND LEGAL SYSTEM AND
CONTRARY TO THE INTERESTS OF
JUSTICE ONLY FULL ELIMINATION OF
THE DOUBLE SEVEN ANTICIPATED
THAT WILL BRING REAL MEANINGFUL
AND LASTING RELIEF TO
CALIFORNIA'S. MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN IS ONE OF
THEM ZERO FOR A PUBLIC COMMENT
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE
DO HAVE ONE MORE IN THE QUEUE TO
BE JUST ONE SECOND HERE. WE WILL
GO TO THE LINE OF THIRTY SEVEN.
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ABOUT MANAGER MEMBER STAFF MORAN
WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
ORANGE COUNTY EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION REGARDING CRYOPORT
FUNDING- WE APPRECIATE THE
INCREASE FUNDING FOR THE TRIAL
COURTS WE ARE CONCERNED WITH THE
LACK OF SPECIFICITY REGARDING
OUT THIS FUNDING WOULD BE
ALLOCATED TO GET THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL BROAD DISCRETION ON HOW
TO ALLOCATE. THESE FUNDS. WE
WOULD AGREE WITH THE L. A. THAT
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD ENSURE
THE FUNDING. PROVIDED REFLECT
THE LEGISLATORS LEGISLATURES
PRIORITIES. AS YOU DID LAST YEAR
WHEN YOU PROVIDED FUNDING FOR
INCREASED PAY GREAT FOR COURT
REPORTERS. AND PLENTY FOR COURT
REPORTERS IN FAMILY COURT JUST
TO NAME A FEW. THANK YOU. AND
MEDICARE WE DO NOT HAVE ANY MORE
PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE QUEUE.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND- PARTICIPATION AND
FACILITATION TO THEM- PEOPLE ON
THE PHONE INTO THE OPERATOR TO
BILLS PRESS INTO THE INTO MY
COLLEAGUES. HE SHE'D EVERYONE'S
INPUT THIS MINISTER TURNED.